all of our simulations of the Buffalo
Bills trading up to get Josh Allen
possibly at number five all of these are
possibilities right now it is man and a
schism I'm getting a chub it's just a
matter of what Denver is gonna ask for
for Buffalo to move up to slide back to
12 is rich so according to Ian rapport
of NFL Network you said Buffalo is not
willing to give up the required two
first-round pick right now go for Josh
ow yeah that's that's what they've been
saying we eater King send his article
only one to get rid of one because they
have a lot of holes in their offensive
line after Eric wood had to retire
Richie incognito retire than trade of
Buffalo may make John Elway pick Josh
chance Josh how I might go to try no we
don't know exactly right so yes don't
there are so that what what is your
prediction for the Broncos I think they
just take chub you think they lot more
can don't find an out for sure I think
they're gonna go Quinn Nelson if you met
Quinn Nelson I mean chub would be so
awesome but damn they got Shaquille
Barrett and Shane ray I just I have a
hard time thinking there the pic is in
though we're getting close yeah cuz look
I looked ahead Shane ray and Shaquille
Barrett they're both free agents after
the season okay I look at their safety
situation I know they have dairy and
Stuart and Justin Simmons are kind of
set their the pick is in do you know the
pick you didn't just Connor know the
pick I do not know the pick okay so do
you want to steal Connors thunder again
no I don't know it's good no I still
just under here so we look you mouth it
to him and then he'll say it yet got it
right Connor right what's the Vick
according to me according to Matt Miller
so I believe didn't set me up here the
Broncos took Bradley choke Wow
now here's the thing - Sims his point
Sims made a good point that they have
depth at this spot but I believe should
kill Barrett hits for agency after this
year so this is a long-term pick yeah
and he'll have a nice an impact he's
better than both of those guys and it is
it's not even trouble over Shea or
Shaquille bag versatility this feels a
lot like the Leonard Williams chat space
it does in your life without a we I know
that deep I know we have Mohammed
Wilkerson and Sheldon Richardson but how
do we pass up Leonard Williams right
Bradley
yeah we don't need to wait for Goodell
we got a little Shum bunch of shows the
combination punch of it's a French hat
making success sure we never like I
wasn't getting tipped like I am this
year I felt like you were actually sorry
for Bradley Chubb I gave it an A+ yeah
I'm going there too how could you double
plus yeah double bunch of unch of he'll
probably be invited to the Von Miller
passing Academy where he can learn and
remember Von Miller said that Bradley
Chubb in his mind was a combination of
Von Miller and Khalil Mack and now
they're on the same team man did he was
one of the safest picks in the whole
draft I mean you at the very least
you're gonna be the guy that goes to a
Pro Bowl a few times he just started on
your defense for the next ten years I
mean he's got it all left go great power
gonna dominate tight ends in the run
game can dominate tackles in the run
game set the edge come off the edge he's
extremely twitchy athlete and as I told
you leading up to this the most
impressive thing is the guy is a hundred
miles per hour on every play and he
plays a lot during the game if he's
Olivier Vernon to me that's what I look
at it's funny the last few years are a
big question to all the pass rushers
were the motor not an issue with him
your grade for getting shove at five man
this is an A+ I am rough on John Elway a
lot this was the the best pick I've seen
him make as GM of the Denver Broncos
because he didn't get cute he didn't
overthink it he just took the best
player on the board and built a strength
for his defense yeah a plus as well it's
just too much of an important position
this day and age defensive end has
become a passing league we don't know
where the rules are gonna go with the
new contact thing and all that as well
I mean Chubb and von Miller off the edge
that is going to be a handful for every
offensive ball when he was at NC State
his coach decided to give him Mario
Williams number number nine as a way to
honor how good he is Mario Williams went
1 Chubb slipped to 5 and now he's paired
with Von Miller AFC West Chargers got a
pass rush Broncos got a pass rush good
luck
quarterbacks Chubb is in Denver
I think bunch of I think this is
something we talked about during our
preview show yesterday we talked about
maybe the Oakland Raiders getting Mike
McGlinchey right man he looks pretty
damn important right now
yes I worry about these guys and Justin
Houston and Bosa and Ingram well he they
got a pretty good old Johnny might have
a better call across the bay go hey Kyle
you used to work for me do a solid and
don't pick Mike McGlinchey I mean
because that's it he's got to worry
about you don't worry about the team in
his own damn City that might take the
guy he wants all right so the Colts pick
is in apparently Wow I'm gonna go quit
Nelson I don't know if they need that
actually I'm gonna change it up I'm
gonna go I'm going role Quan sana I'm
going Tremayne Edmonds now I'm gonna go
quit Nelson I think you're right that
their offensive line is doubtful they
were in on all these interior offensive
line guys throughout the process with
visits with workouts
I think it's quitting else you're right
it's gonna be Quinn I talked to Quinton
there you go
is it go ahead gives in alright let's go
to Connor Colts finally get some
protection Brandon I'm very excited
Quinton Nelson right now is at his lake
house with his friends and family so
shout out to quit Nelson but I look at
their offensive line and the reason why
I think this makes a lot of sense you
look and you go man Costanza you Hort
Ryan Kelly Matt's loss and Denzel good
it's not that bad right but you look
slow some you Horton good all free
agents after this animal not that good
and all in all not not quitting Nelson
good no that's the that's the point plug
and play at all-pro all-pro yeah him and
Ryan Kelly next is Ryan Kelly can you
healthy yeah those two together good
people forget they tie know that Alabama
is a first-round pick yes I mean yeah
people forget people do forget shut up
all right guys amazing I got to do NBC
Notre Dame stuff I saw him all year long
I got to talk to him see him in person
the attitude the body the physical
skills they're everything you want out
of NFL guard this day and age I mean
this is a guy that when your team plays
the Philadelphia Eagles and they have
Fletcher Cox the Indianapolis Colts well
they'll be able to go Oh Quinton can
handle Fletcher Cox by himself we don't
have to worry about reorganizing the
past protections and things
so I have a quote that I can't read it's
not gonna have time in the video this is
a quote from Quinton else about how he
attacks defenders I want to dominate all
my opponents and take their will away to
play the game and finish them past the
witness that's a Jersey Way the Jersey
way let me out of here when you're doing
the read the Old Spice video and Derwin
James and roll Quan Smith right here
yeah quit and I told you this quit and
walked out of the room and they looked
at me and said he's enormous like I
don't even know what to do when he's
coming out that's Quinton Bryson and
he's athletic hey guys guys the
quarterbacks they are all fallen me
likey who's gonna scoop oh I thought for
sure at this point like a few weeks ago
I would have gone yes I probably would
have gone man
Baker Mayfield and Lamar Jackson are on
the board and the other three are gone
all right let's get let's make this
video because now we need to talk about
trades man the draft is so good isn't it
I'd really attack some games over here
just gloat about to take the Browns
picks or the new Justin Gilbert and
Johnny Manziel Wow
oh listen I did he's bitter yeah all
right let's do it the Indianapolis Colts
had to go through a year where Andrew
Luck couldn't see the field why because
he gets hit too damn much well guess
what I don't think that's happening
anymore because quit Nelson the AP
all-american for Notre Dame the first
unanimous all-american since 1993 for
Notre Dame Wow
goes at number six value here he was the
number three player on the board the
best offensive lineman in this draft
class he's a plug-and-play all-pro I
compared him to Steve Hutchinson best
offensive line he's tough he's aware his
football IQ is off the charts you'll see
him so many times he comes out of his
stance gets the D tackle out of the way
it's like oh wait let me let me help out
the guys on the right side cuz they suck
I'll pick up the protection for them
great in the run game this is like you
said Andrew Luck has been hit way too
many tiny times is he and Ryan Kelly
together in the middle of that line
solved that problem
Sims the Indianapolis Colts last year
last of the NFL in sacks allowed 56 how
much does that change with one guy
I mean yes they were banged up on their
offensive line altogether but this guy's
a once every so often type of talent on
the offensive line at the guard position
we talking like Zack Martin I I actually
think he has a true guard he is better
than Zack Martin was coming out Zach
Bowen was playing left tackle and Notre
Dame has seniors last year there
this guy is a guard and he's a guard all
the way and he's a road grader and he
has zero weakness to his game I saw him
in person at every home Notre Dame game
this year
he's even better in person and oh yeah
the new head coach is Frank Reich he
likes to pull guards he likes to run the
ball so that makes sense cuz he's gonna
kick somebody bigger than Zack Martin
Wow
hey this is just a giant man he's a shot
he is a bolt just a block he's a block
with legs sure great man you know this
isn't a plus to get the number three
player on the board and I I do love that
the Colts said we're gonna get Andrew
Luck back hey let's give him some help
let's fix this we can get defense with
all those second-round picks that we
have this is a really really great pick
your speller great you send your purse
back I'm a plus Chris Ballard plus watch
no I mean it's just smart I mean it's
smart for their team they they didn't
overthink it too like Miller says in a
lot of it one of his best phrases yeah
they didn't overthink it's best player
on the board they needed this area to be
improved you've got a lot of money
invested in Andrew Luck and we haven't
had a run game in Indianapolis since I
don't know when it is about time is
really the conclusion they're quitting
Nelson the first pick in the draft for
the Indianapolis Colts at number six and
they got themselves over a good one
all right here at Oh
so your bills are trading those are at
bills are at pic 7 tells no details yet
so I will be shocked if it's not Josh
yeah 100% yeah me too I mean this is the
guy from the start this is New England
Brian day ball this is Shawn McDermott
who came from Carolina and saw the
biggest quarterback in the history of
the sport I just have a hard time
thinking in Buffalo that they wouldn't
want a guy who's thrown in Buffalo type
weather in Wyoming and I'll tell you
what man it's it's cool that they didn't
have to trade up to five where it seemed
like they had to they were able to wait
and these quarterbacks now they only had
to give up two second-round picks up 12
and 12 to second rounds so when you look
at the bills draft stock they actually
had some of the most picks available in
the draft they had nine picks total five
in the first three rounds they had 12 22
and then in the second round they're the
21st pick and the 24th pick so they're
gonna be able to keep their 22nd pick so
if you're the bills here think about
this the bills could trade up take their
quarterback and Josh Allen and then
maybe get like a will Hernandez at 22 to
protect that core I agree there's gonna
be some offensive linemen there that yes
we will make sense a 20 exactly right so
the bills did not have to go all the way
up but Josh Allen with lake-effect if it
is Josh shallow grooms it for me it
would be an A and one thing that
everyone knows this is not a secret that
Allen and I have a relation of
friendship dating you know back over a
year he always thought muscle would be
the team spoon huge stuff was gonna come
get him that's interest I don't know
anything I don't even what why ever
might I do know now just like good oh
now you're sure it's awesome yeah that
gives in yeah yeah come on Connor it's a
good quarterback and it's the biggest
no-brainer ever they didn't have to go
up to number two and that's what they
wanted to go up to number two for this
guy Josh Allen yeah Josh you there boy
now the other side about this now the
12th pick they got in the Cordy Glen
trade right and that's why you know you
had to trade protection to eventually
get your quarterback which
interesting what were your grades a plus
a plus Wow hey Connor stick to football
bet update I keep my hair and mellow
house kit and your brothers getting a
tattoo we had a bet back in November
that if Josh Allen was a top-10 pick or
not right brother who's the co-host
right to get a natty light [ __ ] stamp
because Josh Allen with top ten that's
our serious yeah it's horrible sorry Mel
oh damn oh I had to get a Boulevard
tattoo if he didn't go to great okay
getting nervous are in the sweat I was
getting nervous
all right so and you know what so I look
at the Bucks we're they in a position so
they go back five to 12 maybe they can
get a Derwin James at 12 they probably
go Derwin or Minko will be there we like
both will go back that's what I have a
think that was the first thing that went
through my head and then the Bucks also
get two more picks just good draft
capital yes
man all right you guys let me know we're
ready to make a video we'll make some
magic because when you look that means
now that the Bucks have three picks in
the second round off the six pick and
the other one either offensive line in
the second round that's what they're
gonna do because they didn't have a
third so now they get three picks in
that range
great yep Wow love it okay in every
single mock draft the bills were trading
up but it was usually two five they
trade up to seven and they get their
quarterback the big man with the
powerful arm to handle the wind jaw
sound out of Wyoming yeah you think no I
love the value here he was my number two
quarterback in this draft just a shade
behind Sam darn old we've talked for a
year about the athletic traits I was
actually at that game he has the best
arm I've ever seen and he doesn't miss
plays incredible yes yeah this play we
were saving the press box screaming
which you're not supposed to do though
he every 65 to 45 I compared him to Cam
Newton because yes the accuracy needs
work you see it 56% it's gonna get
mentioned over and over again but the
arm and Chris says it all the time sizes
a trait he has great size very good
athlete and he's only getting better one
year JUCO tears at Wyoming you can't
tell me this kid's been coached great
right I think he's only gonna get better
yeah I'm with you all the way my
favorite quarterback in the draft left
go I mean I think this is the perfect
guy for the bills the bills they got
Ryon day balls their new offensive
coordinator where's he from New England
they want big pocket passing type
quarterbacks not only is this guy big
Miller I will second you you're right
I mean I didn't think I'd be saying this
the year after Patrick my Holmes but
it's the strongest arm I've ever seen I
mean that's what kind of thrower he is
and he is an elite athlete this is the
second best athlete at the quarterback
position in the draft behind Lamar
Jackson so to me it's awesome for them
and it's even better that they didn't
have to leverage the farm to go up and
get him it's good pretty cool to see the
bills they cleared House last year and
now they're ready to start oh and by the
way they went to the playoffs yes while
they clean house
what is your grade for Josh Allen
factoring in the trade up to seven
giving away to suddenly giving up two
seconds I think that's a great awareness
a huge win for them I gave it an A+
everyone knows I like Josh Allen I've
liked the kid since last year he would
have been my top quarterback over Mitch
Travis key in the 2017 draft I like that
they did this I wouldn't be shocked if
they find a way to get him on the field
right away I'm agreed yes because what's
gonna happen I'm giving an A+ so we can
get there but what's gonna really happen
is people on the Buffalo Bills team are
gonna see him on the field next to AJ
McCarron he's gonna throw 10 footballs
and they're gonna oh my gosh this guy is
special and it's gonna change everything
up there for Buffalo but great pic for
them they got their new Jim Kelly man
going forward
very good pretty incredible Josh Allen
grew up on a small grain and cotton farm
and in some scouting services was a zero
star athlete Wow now the 0 started now
he's a seventh pick in the draft in the
future of the Buffalo Bills
Josh Allen goes seven now we're sitting
here with Chicago on the clock at eight
yeah
well anyone come up for Josh right yeah
I just got the Carnales
I got a text people we're trying in the
bear said no okay so they like someone
here a lot I
yesterday on a Dickey show man that like
McGlinchey and Harry hi said our best
friends hey Harry hi stayed just for
everyone that doesn't know was the
offensive line coach for Notre Dame he
is now the offensive line coach I
believe for the Bears yes and he loves
McGlinchey that's a possibility I don't
know maybe linebacker the pics not eat
up linebacker certainly can be applied
that looks precious they need
linebackers trained Edmonds is
definitely on the board go Jermaine
Edmonds that's who I would pick if I
were them I would go with Jermaine
Edmonds
he wondered Alden Smith for Vic Fangio I
mean not even Alden Smith I think he's
more of like he first of all this guy's
an animal in which we've never really
seen before so he's almost like a yeah
he's an anthony bar for Vic Fangio okay
guy a Brian Urlacher best McGlinchey
here you think it's gonna be me gotta go
yeah it's too obvious or anything it's
just us right yeah no and I told you
that before the USC game I'm on the
field for NBC and the Bears scouting
staff was there to look at Notre Dame's
offensive line we were all wrong
we're all wrong that's row Quan Quan say
he's more Patrick Willis dish that's
hunter you want to make the pick for us
no leak yet oh
Miller's a head Miller has it Miller
your shoes gonna Nadya first person the
other pick is in it's Rocklin Wow what
we knew I was gonna curse eventually all
right so what's interesting to me here
now is we still have Josh Rosen well I
wanted to be Jermaine bro Quan like I
just it makes sense a he's more like
Patrick Willis I can see that like for
Vic Fangio it makes a lot of yes yeah
when you look at the the Bears defense
it's funny man the Bears defense was
seventh in against the past 11th against
the rush but right there in the middle
of their linebacker there's an open spot
next to Danny Trevathan it was Nick
quiet Kowski he did a linebacker and I
would say Tremayne ISM has a
huge ceiling I think ro Kwon is more
solid yes I would say that too as well
yes it remains a little bit more of a
projection like I said I think the one
thing that defensive coordinators would
look at her Jermaine Edmonds is my
little one weakness with him just that
he's not always gonna just throw his
body around with reckless abandon what
are your grades for role Quan I gave it
a B+ yeah I'm gonna give it an A - and
now the actually I'm just gonna give it
an a corner true a really yeah now
though the future Super Bowl champions
the fighting [ __ ] Shanahan
all right row Quan smith man from
Montezuma George a Mason County all the
way want to give a quick shout out
Felder and Nelson we love you we miss
you I hope you guys are watching you
guys are the best all their shows
watches broke Juan Smith very
interesting note from shefter yeah
chapter says that the bills and the
Broncos had a trade mapped out and the
Broncos when Bradley Chubb fell to them
said no way we're moving wow so they
waited and then it didn't matter because
then the bills only had to give up
that's why you wait still coming up for
Josh out yeah almost right so but goes
when they saw Bradley Chubb they said
negative ghostrider we're staying pad
and I watch Green Bay here at nine yeah
you think this is where they can make a
move that's what you were hearing before
and you think it's what to make a corner
for Minka Ming car Minka oh that's right
alright whenever you guys are ready
we'll be real quan in this draft there
were certain blue chip prospects that
you just knew what they were gonna be in
the NFL and the Chicago Bears they sat
there at 8:00 and they got one in
linebacker row Quan Smith out of Georgia
the kid flies the kid flies wasn't my
number 10 player in this draft one of
the best linebackers one of the best
defenders he won the Bronco Nagurski
last year and you watch him play shrew
Mike linebacker he can get outside the
hashes he can pull the chain a little
bit and get after the quarterback but I
love the his motor the tenacity that he
plays with and he's more of this new age
linebacker we're in Vic Fangio is
defense he's probably gonna see hey I
had a couple guys like this before and I
know exactly how he's gonna slide in I
like Tremaine Edmunds better for Oakland
Smith there's no doubt he's a very good
prospect
remind you up yeah I mean he's a little
Patrick Willis ish that's why I'm kind
of mad at myself that I didn't call this
out earlier but I mean this guy's a
special guy he really is rock monsters
he's one of the safest picks in the
draft there's no doubt about that I mean
the only thing I could say that it was a
negative about him is that he can play
small at times when guards get on him he
wasn't the greatest of getting off
blocks but you want to talk about
downhill Smasher an impressive explosive
lower body and a guy that's just willing
to he doesn't care he's gonna knock your
head off if you're there to be had so I
really like him it fits the victim
angyeo scheme he is one little
discrepancy I don't like him pass
coverage I think he's a little tight but
they don't ask a lot of past coverage
with their linebacker in the Vic Fangio
defense so it's not gonna be as bad
right go right sum that up
great I gave it a B+ I did like Tremaine
Edmunds a little bit better but I think
ro Kwon comes right in we talked about
it he fills a need for them in this
front seven with the kiemce Hicks
Leonard Boyd who started was pretty good
I think he slides right into a huge role
for them unheard for yeah so George yeah
yes right I mean they were unreal I'm
gonna be in a row Kwan Smith he was one
of the 10 best players in the draft for
me is a phenomenal football player fits
the scheme explosive gonna bring
attitude to this defense and Miller
you're right I mean in this debt
modern-day NFL even to with the screens
the horizontal game you need a guy that
can turn run and go run down receivers
or tie downs or whoever it may be when
Matt Nagy got the head coaching job for
the Chicago Bears when the first phone
calls he made Vic Fangio I need you to
stay Vic Fangio has his middle
linebacker in Rwanda they got him at
number 8 for the Bears
okay so we clear fire here so don't be
afraid to tell me I supporters are gonna
pick Miller's gonna have some news and
then Sims is going to call Kyle Shanahan
live after the selection but it could be
a try it could be the end of our
friendship I've heard the Bucs are
trying to trade up as well to get Darwin
James oh they were trying to trade up
they're trying to come over they're
trying to come back up now holy cow so
they go they get to and they they like
trade one I love when Josh is having fun
that's when pendrick's happens laughs
you're a NASCAR fan
take me through what you want here I
wanted trade you want a trade I want to
trade I would love Tremaine Edmunds here
and I've said all along that the end the
pick is in so I I would love Tremaine
admits I we talked about it in the
preview show I would not be surprised if
it's Mike neva I know I'm going Noguchi
to what I don't ask Kyle these kind of
things because I don't want to know the
answers cuz if I'm right then I can't
say it so but I would think McGlinchey
to the way he talked to me I know
Tremaine Edna's was in conversation and
there was a lot of rumors today about
possibly trading Trent Brown right and I
know it I don't know if that's gonna
happen or not I and we talked about Joe
Staley will be a free agent soon so yeah
is I think that we were all right
yesterday leaning toward McGlinchey
because of yes like you and I talked
about today again make au different Brad
might get traded yes and if the Niners
and I guess they are keeping the pick
McGlinchey makes the most sense I am
gonna be disappointed that it's not
remain Edmonds all right I got the pick
we're talking to my ear I get was hard
to focus Niners Niners took McGlinchey
good that's the right pick it is well
especially when you just paid in your
words a zillion dollars for Jimmy
Garoppolo right yes you did that and you
blew me I don't want to say you blew but
you have a first-round pick from last
year that's a little questionable right
now
and this guy's safe I mean yes I mean
it's just he makes too much sense yes
not sexy but man he's good I know that I
know that but look she's definitely be
down on your board though I know he was
number 22 my board I just I thought he
was a right tackle but guess what he's
gonna play right tackle yeah and this
happens every draft yeah certain
positions to get over draft and we go oh
yeah that makes sense
I'm just glad we figured it earlier this
week but Glyn she could be drafted this
yeah tackles are gonna get over
just sitting there getting the camera on
it cycles are gonna get over dropped it
when they're really good it's a too too
important of a position I mean damn you
know like a person for him was Jack
Conklin if he can just come in here yeah
super salt in their own game and one
thing that oh yeah what are your grades
already gave mine mine should be plus
I'm gonna get I'm gonna give it an A
Connor I said am i mad I'm an idiot
that's for both A's do you know who his
first cousin is Michael McGlinn she's
first as I am I covered Notre Dame this
year you can forgetting that I'm the one
that told you about dick hammer look I'm
like McGlinchey she had a good chin on
that guy oh this guy is Billy so this is
like face of the franchise left this is
Captain America right here I'm telling
you play left yeah I do think eventually
he implies games yeah I think I really
hile scheme one of them I'd I think in
three years from now when he's a few
pounds heavier and a bigger man his only
issue is maybe anchor to a degree but
it's not troubling I mean he played some
big-time pass rushers the last year's
pretty incredible man
pick six picked nine both Notre Dame
offensive line right III mean yeah I
mean you you remember last year when I I
first watched them on film getting ready
for a game that's really good and I was
like oh my gosh I mean this is the best
left aside of the left line and left
side of the line in college football
yeah and some people are like what it's
better than Alabama and I was like I
don't know but this number 56 kids going
in the top 10 and the other guy I
thought was gonna go like in the 20s
let's do Mike McGlinchey to the Niners
at pic number 9 for our favorite coach
in I tell Shannon Dyle Shannon and you
have to call him up as soon as we get to
the of it and then our friendship will
be over it's worth it in a beautiful
trade John Lynch was able to secure
Jimmy Garoppolo and now he's securing
Jimmy Garoppolo yet again with the ninth
pick in the draft Mike McGlinchey that
tackle out of Notre Dame
what do you think of this pick mr. Niner
yeah as a Niners fan I like the pig
because yeah we're gonna protect Jimmy
Garoppolo and I think he's a great
scheme fit in this zone scheme I was not
super high on him as a left tackle but
guess what he's gonna play right tackle
and in two years from Joe Staley retires
maybe you can slide him over so the
value I had a first round great on him
but I did him have him at 22 overall I
think you can watch the
to tape the Miami tip that we're seeing
right there there were some deficiencies
against speed but put him at right
tackle he could be a Jack Conklin like
player right away Sims you know Kyle
Shannon's offense it's a lineman that
fits his scheme without question he does
and I just look at the right tackle they
have on the roster right now Trent Brown
he's a huge man that's just not what
Kyle Shanahan's had in his past he likes
athletic offensive lineman McGlinchey is
extremely athletic you see the length I
do think like Miller is saying in two
years from now when Joe Staley moves on
or retires he will be your franchise
left tackle for the ten years after that
but man the thing that's so impressive
to me and I know why my buddy Kyle
Shanahan liked them it's because the
runn blocking is off the charts I
covered them all year I saw him in
person when I turned on the film I was
still blown away by it so they just
Garoppolo this is Jarek McHale my gosh
yes he is gonna go back it's gonna help
their whole offense what is your grade I
gave it an A I love the idea that hey
let's go protect Jimmy Garoppolo let's
help the run game I think it makes
everyone better they've loaded up with
Western Rick Berg a free agent yes they
interior line play was bad last year I
think McGlinchey and Joe Staley can help
make everything a little bit easier on
the inside so it's an A for this Niners
fan I'm going to a as well yes I think
this guy is a phenomenal football player
that's gonna put your franchise in a
great position for a long time he's
gonna help guard I mean help protect
Jimmy Garoppolo who they've invested a
ton of money into and he just fits what
they want to do scheme wise and the
athleticism at that positions tackle man
in the NFL I mean the 49ers got to play
the Broncos this year they got Von
Miller and Bradley Chubb going on so
it's kind of important number nine yes
the Niners go Mike McGlinchey offensive
tackle how did Notre Dame
okay we got a trade okay what the
Cardinals have traded to pick number 10
I'm praying it's large it's a no-brainer
Rosa you had to get out of the way of me
yes no no I want LaMarcus I want my bold
prediction be right Bruce Arians once
I'm gonna take a little R he doesn't
work there anymore so no I loved that
became a storyline your old coach wants
your team to take a player okay I go to
get your health draft season legitimate
question if yes Rosen for Simms and
Miller yeah is this a bad landing spot
because of how much how poor the
offensive line is right now for a guy
with concussions what did I argue before
the drafts this will be a place that
would scare me because he's he's not
gonna be able to physically carry the
team now they did go out and they did
sign Justin Puetz they have a cue
Shipley are you potty DJ home yeah it's
the only good player that's why they're
available just at 40 million not I can't
talk about I love the guy
yeah he's worth it he was an improvement
to their offensive line and he's got
positional versatility because we're 600
I'm gonna go with that point one I'm
going Lamar Jackson's actually point
zero one man what role room yelling at
you why would they trade up for Lamar
Jackson because they wouldn't I got
these I got the very valid point from
the control room
Wow I do like Rosen in this market
because that is something that we've
talked a lot about if he went to New
York yeah there's a spotlight they
didn't give up much to go from 15 to
tell what are you hearing that from 15
to 10 it costs them obviously flip of
the picks picks 79 and baked 152 yeah
that's and here's the thing too is the
Cardinals had to third-round picks so
they trade one they still now have a
second and third-round pick they were
gonna come out so what is the greater is
gonna do yeah they're raiders I would
like Rosen better with the Dolphins you
know Marcus Davenport or something like
that makes a lot of sense or yeah that's
a good question woody where's woody my
forehead shiny I need some powder on my
face I mean that one but but Josh Rosen
whoa all right so there is the official
one in the fifth
like a third and the fifth to move up
five spots it's not a lot it's not bad
at all in terms of Arizona Mike McCoy's
offense how does Josh Rosen fit into
that I mean it's Mike McCoy's offense
just think about Jake Delhomme back in
the day with the Carolina Panthers
something similar along those range yes
he's gonna fit that totally it's a
pro-style offense it's almost a little
New England Bill Parcells one like that
a lot of them right they want to run the
ball they're gonna drop back and pass
the ball they're gonna look to throw the
ball kind of aggressively down the field
what are you come on in here by the way
I need is your what is your grain if
it's Josh Rosen that's an A it's gonna
be an a-plus for me yes I mean Jeff
Rosen was my second favorite quarterback
in the draft I mean yes for me he is one
of the safest picks at the position in
the draft I'll say this with Sam
Bradford and whatever other awful
quarterback they have in Bradford and
Mike lemon yeah Rosen should start week
one they got the all frail quarterback
squad I mean nobody's got a lot of
muscle or thickness all right I got the
pacing all right let's go to Connor
no-brainer it's Josh rose ah crap Rosen
it's great for hours on the truth that's
close to Southern California it's gonna
bring some of that fan base into the
conversation him being from there I mean
I'm clean about uni ooh yeah yeah that's
an underrated thing that you have think
about one project oh when I got drafted
by the Tampa Bay Buccaneers I was like
what all right so hold I have my random
fact that I'm not going to get into the
video that's great I gotta wear that
yeah what was your great Sims was an
a-plus was your grade Miller let's make
it an A+ A+ Connor
Josh Rosen's father yes was a national
gold medalist in i'ts in ice dancing and
became an orthopedic surgeon and was
once on President Obama's shortlist to
become the US Surgeon General Wow and
Josh Rosen was a tennis prodigy right
which is my favorite part about Josh
right right
I love Josh Rose no so he's not going to
Mary Hill but you know we're Jews going
to get older Florida you do both okay
he's definitely gonna limit Scottsdale
real estate okay he's given the hug
Glasgow did you tell him to give him a
hug he went
Brod there's a little like talking and
mouth yeah that was a for quarterbacks
neck top ten man yep
did you have any bet on that I need any
more natty one ready to go
oh I want on my bed huh I'm set you lost
your Donald Arizona jumps up Josh Rosen
falls down it could be a match made in
heaven Carson Palmer just four tires I
know they got Sam Bradford but guess
what it's the second time that Sam
Bradford got a big contract and a rookie
quarterback came in Carson Wentz now
Josh Rosen what do you think about Rosen
at Ten it's a great value I had him as
the number three quarterback in this
class number eight player overall like
you said they have Sam Bradford so they
had to trade up to get Josh Rosen and
not give up much to do it
prettiest thrower in the draft the
mechanics are on point
she's a matter of candy stay healthy
he's had concussions he's had shoulder
injuries he's not the biggest guy I
think he's a better athlete than he was
giving credit for but he's gonna be on
high alert behind that offensive line I
do think he was the most Pro ready
quarterback in this class and someone
who can come in and play week one if
they need him to and I think they do
need him too because what they have is
not good yeah it's really gonna be just
about whether they feel comfortable at
the offensive line in front of him do
they want him did go out there right
away and have to deal with that but let
go you know my thoughts on this guy Josh
Rosen he was the most game ready ready
to go day one NFL quarterback out of all
these guys
he is a unbelievable throw of the
football I mean he really is it is
consistent it's extremely accurate he's
a great decision-maker
he's got great feel within the pocket as
well and he has a stronger arm than I
think people gave him credit for that
would be one thing I would argue as well
the injury thing it is real certainly
but man just as far as a pure precision
pocket quarterback yet this is I look at
him and I said this is Matt Ryan mate
with a better arm but a hair less
athletic tailor what's your grade I gave
it an A+ am i player compared for
comparison for him was Jared golf so if
you can keep him healthy you can get
that type of quarterback so I think it's
a great trade and a great pick a plus I
mean you're getting what I think is the
second best quarterback in the draft at
what does this pick number 10 they turn
it up to so phenomenal for them and they
the quarterback of the future of their
franchise it's Arizona it's a
small-market team he's from down the
road in Southern California it all makes
sense it's a good pick by that and it
only took them to move up to five spots
a third and a fifth passing base yeah to
get the quarterback of the future Josh
the Rosen one was in Arizona I don't
know the road here's what's interesting
so the Bucks traded back to 12 well
guess what no matter what the Dolphins
do they're going to get minka order one
so that trade now for the box is looking
really nice they're at 12 and the
Raiders move back to 15 they're dolphins
at 11 and yeah a chance they go L'Amour
I don't think so I don't think so i
don't think so they have Tremayne
edmonds available they have if they want
to go safety either of those safeties I
think I'd ever say like minka I mean it
has to be a safety it's got to be
something on defense I know that yeah
yeah it definitely does man what a crazy
draft when you look at the Dolphins
right now they're starting safeties are
Rashad Jones and TJ McDonald yeah if you
look at their linebackers it's Kiko
Alonso Raekwon mental and Stephan
Anthony but vita vega is standing there
right out staring us Rob either where
they got lost and Dominic ensue yeah I
know it to me the linebacker thing is
interesting certainly but you know they
talked highly of Raekwon McMillan before
we got hurt last year in the preseason
what's your prediction by the way
dolphins
I'm gonna go view the vet I said it in
the preview show I think they that mink
if mink over there they would take him
so I'm gonna stick with that okay what
are you thinking I'm gonna go vita van
I'm gonna go Minka as well I think I
know I thought it was gonna be vitae
vita bay as well I just think when I
look at their secondary I think they
need somebody that can just help them
out all together in a lot of few
different areas and make it could do
that we also don't know already do you
know it's your prediction I think it's
gonna be making Fitzpatrick I think he's
a guy that can play a little slot corner
for them he can come down he'll Miller's
nodding at me what do you got Miller its
mica let's make a Fitzpatrick okay
can we get that sound effect with Sims
on camera please
and that is why I do let me guess your
guy's grades on this one yeah I'm gonna
say Miller A+ I'm gonna say Sims na yeah
I think I'm actually gonna I think I'm
gonna join him in A+ land we're given
too many good grades well I mean I don't
know these were guys that I liked I mean
Minka Fitzpatrick I mean I know I'm not
like Johnny big board like you but I had
a major dick I had to make some sort of
a big board and I put on like number
eight or nine I just don't understand
how a player that Nick Saban says when
the best players he's ever coached last
tilden 11 in the draft four quarterbacks
went yeah I get it but it's also like in
today's NFL with safeties and corners
and their versatility in the passing
game and he ran a four for six let's go
what we talked about it the Alabama
thing was hurting him yes I mean I heard
that from too many of you okay sorry
yep shut your mouth shut your mouth man
Tampa should just think Derwin at 12 I
mean I don't think there's gonna be any
doubt that's gonna be the guy was heard
I have been told there was great
arguments within that facility on German
or minka right so what do you feel the
differences are between ball goes video
one of the best players at Nick Saban
has ever coach Minka Fitzpatrick falls
out of the top ten and falls right in
the lap of a team that desperately needs
them the Miami Dolphins great value
great value one of the five best players
in this entire draft class great on the
field great off the field to his
football character some of the best in
the entire class in Alabama moved this
guy around he played outside corner slot
corner single high safety strong safety
he blitzed off the edge and sub-packages
so you're gonna get versatility I'll be
interested to see where am i am ii does
line him up where they try to make him a
corner or if they just let him be a
matchup type secondary player yeah i
mean this is a phenomenal football
player that i've been watching since
high school I mean he grew up here in
New Jersey
I watched him play then he's phenomenal
I know I know what kind of guy is he's
obsessed with the sport I mean he works
at it he lives it every day but as far
as on the football field I mean come on
one of the things
it was hurting him was oh he plays so
many different positions what is he I'll
tell you what he is put him in free
safety and I guarantee he's gonna be one
of the three best free fits free
safeties in the sport
he's Devin McCourty except he's more
powerful in a better open field tackle
er he's gonna be able to play some
nickel slot he's gonna be able to cover
backs and slot receivers man-to-man
coverage and if you're starting corner
does get hurt once week one week he can
go out and play corner I'll say this we
watch the Dolphins clear house with
their leaders in Dhamma consumers Landry
right this is the new face of the leader
shadows and gay war leaders that's the
problem I've said they've talked about a
culture change this is how you do it a
guy who do you get for a Clegg give it
an A+ because he's been compared to jail
and ramsey jamal adams guys who just
love football the wiring which was on
our bingo board last year of my saying
his wiring is great it's an A+ from me a
plus for me as well I mean this is one
of the can't miss prospects of the whole
NFL Draft definitely one of the 10 best
players in the draft for me so many
things he can do for your defense but
again I look at him like our guy last
year from the New York Jets Jamal Adams
Joe bottoms you put him in the box for
run situations maybe more Minko you put
him down there because he's gonna be
awesome at covering tight ends backs out
of the backfield he won the Chuck
Bednarik award and the Jim Thorpe Award
he is one of only three players to ever
do that him Charles Woodson and Patrick
Peterson and you got him at 11 Minka
in my end
all right so Bucks are taking Derwin
we're gonna go site on sink I would
think I Got News for you
oh oh but first of all is that three
people from New Jersey in the top ten
eleven okay not bad for the Great's not
bad
sorry alright what you got for us to not
Derwin this one's a shocker the Bucks
took Vita veía wow wow I hate that that
is that a shock for you guys I just
wasn't expecting it I mean I look at
their secondary the right weakest things
on their team you at the same point
though yeah they were 32nd in the NFL in
passing they were 32nd the NFL in sacks
23rd against the rush but if you look at
the inside their starter next to Gerald
McCoy was beau Allen yeah they don't
have bow-bow-bow Allen is your number
one d tackle but with all the rumors for
this whole process being safety I think
that's where it's really a surprise I
mean I would have trade it back again I
would have found a trade partner I I'm
not gonna be too mad about this facebook
comments are calling you guys soft
graders yeah so I'm gonna give it a seat
all right
whoa I mean I gave the first drug I've
gave the first pick of the draft a
c-minus
but yeah I mean listen these guys these
were a lot of these guys are the guys we
thought we're gonna go here they were
all the easy picks this is the top tier
of the class I mean I don't think there
was any denying this in any of our eyes
we didn't know they're gonna go in this
order but there hasn't been like any
name that's been out there yet there we
go oh wow I didn't expect this guys do
you know what Vita veis full name is
nope not Vita via Tavita to lea kyono to
e pulo toe mo sees the heya fully towel
whoa yeah that's a lot it's up chances
you got that right I'm gonna go a -
Connor oh you're changing it what did I
skip McGrady yet no you didn't okay so
shut your mouth I want to frame it to
you like this if the Bucks secondary is
an absolute mess again and Derwin James
is one of the better rookies the NFL is
this pick a mistake no matter what Vito
Bay it does yes the only thing I would
argued with the Derwin James thing right
was I don't think it's a scheme that
necessarily fits him they're a what
Derwood James what is he going to be
he's in the Box a downright we all look
at that so but they have that
I mean so maybe that that to me was
where I was like man Minkus seems more
right for them they just they also at
every corner still available on the
board oh yeah Denzel Ward but Vita VII
so why does this as this change the
Tampa Bay Bucs now I don't think he's
the difference maker I do I do
so do we want to wait to the video or do
we want to tell the other greats I know
but we're not doing the video yeah the
video right now okay that's waiting for
TV let's do it
no I was just saying did you want to
talk it out right now or start the video
though save it for the video pal Tampa
Bay finished fourth in the NFC South
last year and they're starting in the
trenches to start building back up Vida
via an absolute mountain of a man from
Washington is the pick at 12 what are
you thinking of selection well I had him
at 16 overall so I think the values a
little bit off especially with players
like Derwin James still on the board and
their need in the secondary
Veta Bay is a very good player I think
he was the best defensive tackle in this
class he is a monster of a man and his
pursuit is amazing he was the best in
the class at stacking up double teams
splitting and I've said before he's a
disrupter he's not gonna be a true
penetrator but he is a much better
athlete than you would expect for a guy
who's going about 345 yes I mean listen
I like this guy a lot I'm higher on him
than you are I think yes at 347 pounds
41 bench press reps I mean it's an ugly
body let me just tell you when I turned
on film I said wow he is ugly looking in
that uniform you're right that he's
gonna have an off C wall for years from
now then won't Lee negative is he has
one bad off seasons gonna be 390 and
you're gonna oh we need just put in a
weight plan here for him but talking
about the player right now he's
extremely disruptive he's a freak of
nature on the football field I've never
seen anybody that looks like him in the
football uniform it has that size B is
disruptive as he is him with Gerald
McCoy watch out that is gonna be some
tandem the deal disappear Paul now yes
David benefit right and they've invested
in the defensive line absolutely have
you really have so what's your great I
gave it a seat I just don't know if he
can get off blocks short arms you saw it
32 and a quarter inch arms not great for
a guy whose pad level was
then at times and I think they're gonna
regret not taking dirt with James here
well this is a 4-3 defense right I'm
gonna give it an A - okay
because I do think that secondary was a
greater need for them right here but I'm
not gonna kill this pic I think this guy
is a difference maker
it's a 4-3 defense I don't worry about
the long alarms just because maybe you
won't have to hold up to gap people but
man who's our defensive coordinator
there Mike Smith Mike Smith it's back to
like his Jacksonville days he's got this
huge defensive line now that can
overpower people so that makes sense
yeah this was a team that was last in
the NFL in sacks and now across the
board they go jpp Gerald McCoy Vito Vega
Vinny curry and I don't think they're
gonna be last in sacks next year hold
the pirate's life for me it does always
they have a sentimental place in my
heart
for sure yeah Mike's made a baby down
there all right so now at 13 Washington
what are we thinking for the for washing
Derwin Jones they just lost two of
Cravens people say their next Sean
Taylor I just feel like it's oh yeah
that's right yeah I had Derwent on our
podcast and you say that he gets
compared to Sean Taylor I also think
that this is the worst front office in
the NFL do you
so Bruce at well Bruce Allen's
definitely up there right
I've never think about my Bruce like
that I'm sorry I have no faith in this
front office for there any other
positions there a possibility here could
they go for a Landry or a Davenport
could they go for an Edmunds who now at
Virginia Tech right there the state of
Virginia is suddenly available at third
I mean they could go corner again to me
they can also DTAC alike I bet you they
were a team to go Dan I think they just
left off the board because they have not
had that I mean there's no gray NFL and
stopping the run let's take a look at
Matt and they have Jonathan Allen right
yes who was injured for summer I are
waiting it to say these full
capabilities but safety running back and
I this is Matt Miller's
fun Derwin James is there Connor
Williams but yet Davenport
that's athletes Golu yeah and guys who
are a little role a trained admins as
y'all
look at the secondary of Washington
right now they have Josh Norman Orlando
Scandrick
yeah but it's safety it's DJ swear
injure and the other starter right now
DeShazer Everett yeah German James is
the picture I would think so it makes
too much sense to me I mean value at
this biggest baby I mean listen I I you
know maybe they parature main admins of
them I got it got a better breed defense
that's all it has to be deep Derwin
James you just lost sua Cravens right
because he decided to quit on the team
and now he's on the Denver Broncos going
to Tremaine Edmonds with Zac Brown yeah
well they have a very good I mean they
have a lot of talent on the outside with
Preston Smith yeah their holes are at
safety and defensive tackle yeah pretty
man the defensive tackle went and the
safety still there's I mean it's a when
gyre Alexander or somebody like that I
wouldn't be mad at them I would get it
yeah but yeah the other guys you're
talking about left coast the only other
hole that I see that's glaring on this
team but I think the value is there is
at the center or guard position yeah I
lost Shawn Laval I think early for that
that's what I'm saying the value is not
there but you lose Shawn Laval you lose
your center Spencer long but I don't
think you can reach for a will Hernandez
or somebody right now know pretty good I
don't look at it as like desperate I
guess yeah it's a good life and you have
tread Williams yeah and Morgan Moses is
good yeah I it should be James but we
thought that was her win what's the
great anything hey oh yeah Derek
durman's definitely good Derwin was well
you know when I had to do my top twenty
board
derman was like right on my fringe of
ten or eleven I think I had a mad so so
it's not it's defense oh let's do the
ding and I want Connor with the way he
looks disappointed Connor I am get it
I'm fine Pete this front oh I thought
this guy would go outside of I thought
he'd go or a top around - Doron Payne
defensive line out ok so I want to say
something you know where Doron pains
from Alabama this front office can't
evaluate talent so they just go let's
just take a kid from Alabama that we did
it last year they do it on Allen I think
you guys are freaking wrong I think drop
because I think Ron bans really good
I think he was really good against
Clemson I mean I liked a period I daddy
Connor okay
d4 dumb I'm excited because I know a lot
of friends that Doron Payne spends a lot
of time in the Washington area and I
think this is amazing
but Jerrod pain so you're saying that's
a little bit overrated
Connor sale overrated Sims you're
disagreeing here I am I really like
Tehran pain I thought he was definitely
in one of the 20 best players of the
draft
I mean Durham pain when I watched him I
thought the things I've wrote I wrote
this is Kiwanis or this is this is gonna
be one of the better defensive tackles
in football for me you know he just he
had a little bit of everything he's
kidding he can be the guy that can make
a mosh pit of the run game and take on
double teams and he can be disruptive -
I really liked him man your grades
I gave it a D what did you give it Sims
I am going to give it an A oh and this
is why I was so happy that Sims and
Miller didn't do you want me to read
just like my little thing by before it
become now I'm gonna make the video and
read it so we got all this time we got
no commercials shut up here we go
I wrote the video I'll find it I just
say I mean powerful-looking DT body is
not perfect like Seward Donald not quite
as proportionate but man the kid still
has a good body you could tell he's
thick with dense muscle it's not mush
let's see not far in I already impressed
the paint already - anything in the
interior D line I wrote he can be three
four or four three he can definitely -
gap because he's strong as hell but I
think he would really thrive in a 4-3
nose tackle or three technique situation
exactly then what you see Miller that
was different from what Simpson three
sacks in college that's it
but is that were they asking him - yeah
I mean it's Alabama scheme you're I mean
there were times he was asked to be a
cog and a little bit and just take on
blockers but he was a flash player one
year starter so that's a concern for me
and I know they had talent there but
just a one year starter and I just don't
see him as the type of consistent player
that you draft in the top I think we
have to be careful with the Alabama guys
at times this is my assistant I'm not
yeah what we're hip we'll see in two or
three years whether who's right or wrong
to me though with the Alabama guys
you've got to be careful in the d-line
because they're never they never take
the reins off very rarely
- just go I want to say this also the
say no he's got a created up to 14 with
the Packers if Lamar Jackson is with
Sean Payton and under Drew Brees I think
they're gonna go Harold Lynch
I think they're gonna pass rush yeah
okay well a good dream
I just want the Marge accident all right
so don't let it go all right so you you
do your whole Alabama spiel - when we do
this we're gonna do a video right now
you forgetting who we're talking about
Geron pain Washington was sitting there
at 13 and a lot of good players fell I
know there's been surprise here that
they went Doron Payne defensive lineman
out of Alabama not so high on him super
high on him so you're getting the full
gamut why are you not that high under on
page well I think you look at a
defensive lineman about three sacks in
college that's a problem for me and he
was a flash player who looked great
against Clemson we didn't see him do
much the rest of his career so he is an
up side guy item ranked 34th overall I
thought he was a second round player and
we saw here a guy who's probably a nose
tackle go 13 overall when dirt when
James was on the board the their
safeties are so bad I like to run paint
I really do I just don't like him this
early in a draft that has pretty good
depth of defensive line where you could
have taken a Harrison Phillips in round
two and got a difference-maker at Darwin
James alright now the positive derived
yeah I really like Doron Payne I mean I
just look at Doron Payne first of all
you got to think about this with Alabama
guys Alabama defensive line they're
never allowed to just tend their backs
and go Vick save and they to gap they
make them read everything hold up your
defender then discard and go when he's
allowed to go and they played one gap
schemes like a 4-3 Thames game at times
of time man he can win with athleticism
he started enough to take on double
teams he could be a three technique or a
shade nose I mean listen he's 311 pounds
and he ran for nine five two so that
tells you he's got an explosion I am a
big fan of the guy I think there's a lot
of things he can do for your interior
buddy freshman in high school yeah it
was a 300-pounder that could dunk a
basketball he's one of those guys yeah
what is your grade this is gonna be
interesting
as a freshman high school he could dunk
as a deal I'm in a color couldn't sack
the quarterback I'm gonna give it a D
there were so many better players on the
board again 34th overall I think it's a
reach he'll be a good player he'll be
solid but I
think he's a transcendent talent you
take this early I'm giving an a I think
he will be a dominant player I look at
him as almost like a : short me and
Miller are were different here I thought
he was in the conversation we're one of
the 20 best players in the draft and I
evaluated him hey the Redskins we've
talked about it for years they had to
get bigger and more physical in the
middle at least they're doing that I can
give him credit for that Washington was
the last the worst team in the NFL in
stopping the run and they're hoping that
Doron brings the pain get the simple
Sims laughs that's all I want all right
what are the trade details for the
Saints moving up to 14 from 27 like a
lot baby cuz they gave up their first
rounder this year their fifth round pick
and their first rounder next year Wow
yeah
so you're thinking Landry it makes me
think but I just say this it's so good
this is me my thing the Saints have to
be in what mode right now when the Super
Bowl when the Super Bowl they're playing
for the Super Bowl they really need a
password I think that's where I go I'd
say I think pass rusher but i mean i i'd
heard pass rusher all along i did but
that was also at 27 so let me ask you
yeah is it
Marcus Davenport or is it Harold Landry
who fits into that scheme better I think
Harold Landry does you totally different
I'm Carolann three as well I think
Harold Landry with the guy but hasn't he
been so fun but yeah
what is the difference for everybody out
there between those two guys
I mean Landry smaller he's built like
Cameron Wake and his move is that
shoulder dip accelerate with really
really smooth hips he's a bender
Davenport is he wins with first step
quickness and length a little bit more
that and and but he is a developmental
guy he's he's probably going to play on
third downs right away so I think Landry
is just much cleaner as okay come in and
play right now Landry I think has a
higher up side just because of what he
can do coming off the edge
he's excuse me he is a special first
step ability to bend his body and put it
in positions that you can only see elite
pass rushers in the NFL do he can get in
positions where I could go Oh only the
von Miller's and the
Max and some of the other top-tier
bachelors in the league can do so I look
at that I look at a Harold Landry his
ability to handle the Tynan and the line
of scrimmage set the edge it's all very
good the scene the last year's films
gonna want you wanting more yes but then
when you go back to the year before when
you let Kyle trouble and sacrifice what
do you guys will you guys 16 and a half
you guys help me here
is there any chance that this is for
Lamar amazing because were the rumors
that Sean Payton really liked Lamar
Jackson yes and the reason I want Lamar
to go to the sites or a team like this I
know it's very unlikely is Lamar is
gonna be judged so critically and if he
gets to work under Drew with Sean but I
understand what you're saying they need
to win now yeah my the pick yeah in it
sorry it would be awesome let's go it'll
surprise you a little bit
they took Davenport yeah okay they took
the guy that has more upside than Landry
but is not as close as him in terms of
being a pure sack mask now Sims in our
mock draft Sims had Davenport going six
so you see a special seal I mean listen
the only thing that misses from
Davenport's game is special Bend around
the edge which is what Landry would what
Landry had you got four grains last year
would scare me great b-plus for me oh
man what am I gonna give this you know
what I'm gonna mmm I'm gonna give it an
a-minus
so you like this guy I do like this guy
yes I do I have from the start when you
look at this team they got cam I think
he's a very safe pick to like I don't
think yours no way you're getting a bust
you might not get Harold Landry 15 sacks
a year which he could be capable of yeah
but I think he's gonna be disruptive and
a pain in the ass it's tough because
this team was gonna rely on Alex Okafor
and hey Olli kikaha and both of those
guys got hurt you need a guy in there
they can get after the quarterback
because this is a Saints team look they
were seventh in the NFL in sacks last
year but I don't know if that was gonna
happen if they didn't take this guy this
year he just he's still figuring
everything out okay and that's the key
small so I told the story before we
summoned Senior Bowl and day one I was
like this is the guy for what he's
talking about day two you were like okay
and then day three you're like holy hell
this yeah this guy's amazing
my comparison for him was Alden Smith
with no off field that's really good
let's do this video then
Alden Smith if there wasn't a Minnesota
miracle the Saints maybe could have made
a Super Bowl run and they're trying to
make another one trading a future first
and their current first up to 14 and
taking a pass rusher that's got size and
speed Markus Davenport tell people who
this is because I don't think many
people watch Texas st. Antonio the small
school guy remember when a scout text me
said I just watched this kid at UT San
Antonio and he's a first-round pick and
I thought the guy was drunk well guess
what he's the first-round pick he was
number 14 on my board overall so great
value as you see how much he'll end up
he looks like a small Ford and my
comparison for him I've said it a
million times people are tired of
hearing it was Alden Smith his combine
numbers or Jadeveon Clowney so he is a
rare athlete it's just you got to coach
the guy up but you know the Saints had a
legendary historic draft last year yes
if they like this guy I'm not gonna say
anything bad about the pick cuz they're
probably right well yeah I mean there's
a lot to like about the guy when you're
6 6 264 pounds and you run four or five
man there's just not a lot of people on
planet there you go how you like them
apples but hey the only thing that's
missing from this guy's game is Elite
bend around the edge physicality
smashing in one side of the offensive
line in the run game playing with a
motor
everything is their length on the arms I
think he's one of the safer picks in the
draft I really do
he's certainly one of the top 20 players
in the draft for me and what did they do
last year man they went in and fixed
this defense with a lot of draft picks I
know they got Alvin Kamara hey and he
was a great player for them but they
were aggressive fixing the defense it
paid off and a lot more and of course
like Marcus Williams right good picks
what grade you get for Davenport at this
spot and factoring in the trade so the
trades the only reason I'm giving this a
b-plus because it would have been an A
pick for me but they gave up a lot
they're not gonna have a first-round
pick next year they're probably betting
that that picks gonna be 32 overall
though I am giving it I believe it what
did I give it an a-minus hey yo hey
nailed it yes good hey - I wasn't sure
there but yes I am I mean yes they gave
a lot but I'm not gonna be mad at this
picker for them trading up a lot Drew
Brees has got two years left they're
trying to win the super
this year and next year this was the
most glaring need on their team and they
might have this is I thought he was
DeMarcus Ware coming out okay so I
thought he was pretty good we'll see how
it works out
all right I'm Worland you had an amazing
year last year like you said dominated
the draft yeah let's see if they locked
in another future superstar with the
14th pick and Marcus Davenport the
Raiders take a lot more chance right
it's pretty shocking both are there yeah
right now okay so that thought der wien
Derwin James was top-five player the
best player in the draft I had people
tell me and things like that
I mean people I respect them I wouldn't
just throw out crap that I don't know I
mean I I know one thing I I think it was
late in the season I tweet it was like
man derma James does not look the same
this year and he was coming back off a
knee I wonder if there's something with
that that you know you got falling down
a little right so if I'm looking at the
Raiders right now I don't know if you
pair up Landry with Khaleel Mac of
course Tremayne Edmonds is a team that
needs desperate athletes with linebacker
position to take care of Landry and then
of course there's all the cornerbacks
this is a team that really doesn't have
corners and everyone other than Denzel
Ward is still um I think my man Johnny
would love him some Shire Alexander
attitude on his defense I will tell you
that much so the Gyre Alexander clip
yeah when they're playing I think it was
Florida State and he popped up and he
was like this behind him have you seen
that close oh it's the Disney got flag
though is it that's the issue with him
yeah all right so what's your guess here
pal we talked about offensive tackle all
along and they McGlinchey is gone so I
think it's Colton Miller oh are you
hearing something you know Tom cable
loves Colton Miller okay so so you think
there's things you hear throughout I'm
gonna go Tremaine Edmunds I can't
believe Tremaine Emmons is still here to
be honest that's too smart for them I
heard Kay got the pick guys all right
I'm gonna go Tremaine Edmunds - all
right he's gonna Connor my board a lot
of people were onto this one but they
went with Colton Miller their offensive
line some help a guy that Sims are you
roll on time out I got a throw a
challenge flag Sims you think Miller's
cheating yes
that's okay no one takes me my latter
axis overt we do whatever you got so
many tabs Tom cable saying the Tom cable
thing was real that's early well that's
fine yeah you're right I mean you're
still cheating is good information to
that Oh Miller cheats yeah you guys
think it every year I don't care
but don't you do it really well cuz
you'd be like I don't know top cable
old Miller you silly old Miller UCLA
right so plugged in I'm sorry that you
can't handle I gotta give it a beat yeah
I'm gonna give it like a B - Mel yeah I
just want to say something yes this is
my least favorite pick in the draft and
it's not even close I would say to this
plant even it's up there with me -
horrible well Baker may feel that one is
up there too
man I can actually change my grade yes
I'm gonna leave my B - that I want to go
see - was it falling off that far
because Tom cable can't evacuate talent
okay I dare you I don't we'll get to
hear my real opinions of NFL coaches on
the Facebook live thing I'm asking you -
it'll be all right like man you're kind
of a dick yep and you just curse
together I don't care that's cursing no
jerk can I get a that is cursing that's
good never mind safe no it's no good
yep male parts are not good don't say it
again okay it's interesting too is it's
like--
what's this is what Fidel Alexander at
right tackle
is he a wonder no they had a marshal new
house last year yeah he's a day one
story he's probably left tackle yes I
know another team a team picking the top
ten thought Colton Miller was the best
left tackle on the dress is that right I
didn't see it I didn't either I just
supposed oh man he's getting just
hitting the teeth right
the Raiders trade back there was talk to
they Michael offensive line and they
were able to get some pics in the
process 15th they go the UCLA product
Colton Miller and we have some mixed
reviews up here even though you're
saying that Tom cable like this guy's
loose tom cables guy coming out of the
combine that was what I heard and he is
a very good athlete my comparison for
him was Nate's older but I had him 32
overall my board he is a work in
progress he's a great athlete he
dominated every drill to combine I'm
sure they're gonna show you his numbers
and they're gonna look pretty but
there's a reason Josh Rosen was one of
the most hit quarterbacks in the NFL
last year so I see him as a work in
progress and I also have zero faith in
Tom cable because I saw him do this in
Seattle yes drafting guys who they still
have one of the worst offensive lines of
football valid points certainly all of
those yes cold Miller I mean he a body
standpoint he is your prototypical left
tackle I mean with that size the length
everybody you heard everybody compare
him to Nate's older and the NFL Draft
all that but he does play high he's not
a great run blocker that would be one
thing I look at and yes his anchor is
questionable I mean I would worry about
him the first time the Denver pass
rushing duel got a six yard head start
and came into his chest and whether he
can actually hold his ground for many
Derrick - center of gravity absurd well
it is right and he's still he's gonna
get bigger and all that the thing I do
like though it was a true position of
need for the Oakland Raiders and they
have given Derek Carr a lot of money and
he's the quarterback of the future yes
great for this pick I know you think
it's a reach yeah it is reach I give it
a c-minus now I was just reading my
notes like while Chris was talking a
scout told me this guy's soft he's not
gonna be ready to play right away he's a
work in progress man I just don't I
don't like it see - yeah I give it a
b-minus but that would be my concern
Miller I mean that was the the thing I
wrote in my notes is you know doesn't
play the game with a physical edge he's
not nasty but it was a position of need
he does have potential to be that
franchise left tackle I mean he's going
to be but he's just not the perfect
prospect yet and we are getting to that
point in Donald Penn's career where he's
gonna have to be replaced and they
haven't had a really a right tackle for
the last two years
protection for John Gruden's offense hey
this is my kind of guy Miller at the
pick for the Raiders down there 15
we have a trade another one well bulls
move up they've got the details remain
Edmund the Ravens get the 22nd so they
switched from 16 to 22 and it's a swap
of a third for a fifth so really not
that much for the bills to move up what
do you think the bills are moving back
up to get it's got to be an offensive
lineman no I mean the middle linebacker
thing is you know this is Sean majora
main and oppressive
if the bills leave this draft with Josh
out and Treme Timmons and get very
strong best athletes in this trash yep
they fired on my friend so I don't know
I won't know this one you know I mean
got the pit guys oh there's mommy got a
new member
it's germane Ed McMahon the bills
killing it man I want to say this I
questioned the bills a lot when they
were getting rid of all of their players
or the last few years where there was
the Sammy Watkins and all those moves
but man it's worked out they know the
type of team they want it's a super
power based in your face and to get the
speed of Tremayne Edmonds on the back
end to get him at this spot is crazy
it's crazy
I mean it's racist but this was my
ultimate man crush to the whole jury
yeah he was up there for me as well and
and really to me is just the epitome of
the modern day yes
NFL middle line this is what you wanted
to be for yeah Kuechly Thomas David
except he's like he's a lot taller and
longer and bigger I mean it's just gonna
be this is again like I look at where I
would say like Josh Allen is the
modern-day Troy Aikman I would go like
this guys like your modern-day okay so
let's say Luke Kuechly I mean this is
what people are gonna look for now that
blank feed variables this modern-day
also they need a went like all the a
pluses I can have he's replacing tunner
Viejo oh you can give me an A+ still my
soft a-plus this team was 29th in rush
defense I think that's gonna change the
both a-pluses yeah I'm really impressed
you're wearing your favorite shirt
though every other day we do a podcast
he wears this shirt so it's
it's the color of a team that just won
the Super Bowl Philadelphia Eagles have
you heard of them huh it doesn't look
that green Treme devil Wow Wow
I love this a rock you know what I think
there's a reason when when Shawn
McDermott took the bills job and Brandon
bean came with him
those guys were both in Carolina
together and you know that they were
probably getting together go man if we
ever get a crack at this to build our
own team they're just always I think
that's that because of like you said
they they came to a clean house and they
still made the playoffs
yes I think that's why they have a
little bit of and almost beat the Jag
they have a little bit of a leash to
take these objects and Josh Allen and
Schmidt Edmunds instead of all we got to
get Josh Rosen in and roll quants Meath
yes no they can take guys that need some
time because they do have a cushion
built in because they were so successful
last year man that's my rant that was
good
exciting Thanks I do like this draft a
lot for the bills and I'll tell you what
the fact that he gets star loot alele in
front of him - yeah it was a good free
pick i williams who still somehow
playing the bills are moving and they're
shaken earlier they traded up for Josh
Allen at a position where many people
thought maybe Tremaine Edmonds would go
but they get this guy at 16 and we're up
here talking about him like he's a
generational Talent
tell him how good this though I had him
number four on my blog buddy he's a
really good talent he turns 20 next week
that's how young he is he could play
anywhere on defense I've compared him to
Anthony bar Brian Urlacher he's just an
athlete and this is where the NFL is
going if you want to run a spread
offense this is the guy who can take
away all those rush lanes he can come
off the edge as a pass rusher he could
carry tight ends up the seam again
number four on the board and you just
got him as 16 I might have to be a Bills
fan Chris yeah I mean he's one of my man
crushers of the draft I'm with you I
mean this is one of the best specimens
in the draft as well and the player fits
the scheme need as well I mean this is
Shawn McDermott he came with the
Carolina Panthers it's Thomas Davis's
Luke Kuechly athletic middle linebacker
athletic middle linebackers this guy is
them but bigger
I mean faster stronger longer everything
you want I've never seen a kid like this
it's it's truly unbelievable and I know
guys I've said this to you before I got
a chance to play against Brian Urlacher
once when you have that size of a middle
linebacker that athletic in the middle
of the field it's extremely intimidating
for a quarterback to throw the ball in
that area cuz you just go wow he's
really fast wow he's really lie he's a
true middle linebacker great pick yeah
so I know you were gonna give me a good
grade really wherever he went yeah to
get him at sixth oh my gosh so really
only they've all my third-round pick and
you got fifth in exchange yes how many
pluses can you guys put next to my grade
here give this in hey just one well I
would have put seven pluses bite if I
could he's one of my favorite players in
the entire draft yeah a plus here all
the way I mean again this is a position
of need for the Buffalo Bills it great
importance this position to the success
of Shaun McDermott's defense they had
nothing like this at the position it
makes sense and he has the type of size
and athletic ability in at the age like
Miller said he has Hall of Fame
potential this type of guy when I look
at him yes I'm saying again I know how
much Simms cares about mom athletics his
mom was a college hurdler his dad a
two-time Pro Bowler for the Miami
Dolphins right iswhat Tremayne gets a
face the Dolphins two times a year the
bills they got athletes right now
look out for that next season oh okay so
the bills are one of those teams I'm
just gonna say this as a Philadelphia
fan where you go through all of those
years of not winning a Super Bowl I
always like felt the bills you know what
I mean losing all those Super Bowls and
now that they're sort of turning the
page I'm happy for Bills fans man I am
too man I want to see them successful
and Bill's have one of the best fan
bases in football easily who the
craziest definitely okay so the Chargers
are at 17 my prediction is easy my
prediction is Lamar Jackson last year
Chris Sims tell me if I'm correct they
wanted to take to Shaun Watson but
Phillip Rivers said I'm not ready to be
a mentor just yet and I was correct with
my Shaun mahomes than a swan the day so
let me ask you something
I know that the Chargers met with them
and they love them rest yes they did
now this is a team like the Saints who's
very close to maybe making a Super Bowl
run
and they could use some other pieces
safety is still sitting there
Derwin James is still sitting there but
I like their second Terry Lamar but this
might be the one guy that could trump
Lamar for them turban James yeah because
this is Gus Bradley and he's trying to
get kam chancellor and that's what
Durbin James can be so that's right I
mean and I'm sure see yeah all these I
jumped behind them going damn I hope
they don't take German James we'd like
art and I saw Derwin Mach 2 the Chargers
and a few I did as well right right I
really thought this might be a spot for
beat avail but yeah if Darwin's there
he's got think has to be the guy yeah
they certainly could do there's no D
tackle of value here I know I kind of
had pencil them in with a deer on pain I
think one of the offensive linemen were
here maybe like if a tackle I wouldn't
go guard here ya know and I also don't
think I don't know where this notion
that the Chargers offensive his bad
started I don't get it I would just take
Darwin James just be really happy oh you
don't kiss again you you take it oh
there it is it's here it's a my boy
finally Darwin James Irwin there he is
makes too much sense Cowboys got to be
pretty disappointed right now right I
think that all those two teams after I
think the Seahawks and the Cowboys right
now are going we were so freaking close
yeah I don't think the Cowboys were as
desperate I think that one I think the
Cowboys are sitting we're about to get
our pick up any Rashad Evans or DJ more
the two thinner you know your receiver
right they aren't Sean Evans I mean I
mean there's a pick away but I think
it'll be van der dude I'm excited for
Derwin though because they're this is a
thing a lot of people and der one's been
sitting there and he's thinking about
all the money he's lost he's going to a
contender he's living in LA and he's
playing on a defense in which the
quarterbacks being pressured by Bosa and
Ingram and he gets to be on the backend
collecting it and he's playing with like
a Jason Verret yeah this is a perk this
is a lot this is my favorite tea other
than right so he's locked in between
them yeah look out for the Chargers
right now before the season the Chargers
were at about 20 to 1 to win the Super
Bowl so we're the Saints throw like $100
on make two g's and then send me a
hundred back don't bet on Sam Darnell
being the first pick in the draft wait
so wait this is what I wanted to say
this is
I was moving so fast I can't even keep
up it's ten minutes I think it's to the
fifties that thing of the Ravens trading
back the Ravens are definitely one of
the teams that are interested in our boy
Lamar they are yeah they say he went to
where they went to 22 what are grades
under what is a little more a plus a
plus yeah I'm going a plus two so I'm
just gonna say this before we get to
this video we are at 21 and 22 I'm very
afraid for my man Lamar Jackson at 21 is
the Bengals
I don't want Lamar to go there at 22 is
the Ravens I do like that situation for
Lamar Jackson because I like the front
office
I like the coaching staff right and I
know that their OC has worked with Mike
Vick before when he was in Philadelphia
so I'm really worried that he goes to
Cincinnati I just don't trust bill lazer
I don't like the system right but I'm
gonna buy quarterback anytime soon so
Andy you'll get bill laser fired and
they'll bring somebody in and Lamar will
take over the next guy came out this
morning was that Seattle is a trade back
spot like we've talked about it alright
I think someone could come up right now
for a quarterback oh but for somebody
yeah I would expect Seattle they they
don't have her me picks they've been
talking about trade now forever we're
ready to do Derwin awesome
hey Conor flex for me give me some
biceps
there are certain players when it drafts
going on you look at them and you go why
is this guy falling no one has any issue
but teams just don't need him for some
reason well Derwin James just fell into
the lap of the Chargers at 17 a dominant
defense just got real nasty there's no
way that you could have predicted he
fell this far no I mean there were times
where I thought maybe he goes around 15
just because of when he runs in these
scenarios the quarterbacks gonna go
really a couple offensive tackles are
gonna go early but I am surprised he was
still here I think it's a great spot for
him it's a great pick for the LA
Chargers I had him as the number 11
overall player on my board so to get him
a 17 and to fill arguably the biggest
position needed for them their run
defense was awful last year I think he
can really help in the box and you see
84 tackles he was coming back from a
knee injury that took almost all of his
2016 season so he's still shaken off
some of the rust he's a phenomenal
football player I mean the San Diego Los
Angeles Chargers excuse me they just got
their camp Chancellor Gus Bradley your
defensive coordinator he came from
Seattle
he runs the same Seattle scheme and now
you got cam chancer except he is a lot
better than camp Chancellor was coming
out of college I'm just gonna tell you
that this guy's special he was
definitely one of the 10-12 best players
in the draft
you have Miller's right it didn't work
out with team needs and the quarterback
and all that but he will knock your head
off if he is gonna be a leader in the
locker room and he's gonna give this
defense attitude all right I've got the
grade for Derwin at seven man this is
honestly one of my favorite picks the
entire draft so far I give it an A+
Phil's in need I also think he's just
like the right guy to sell some tickets
out there with yes let's be honest they
need to do he's gonna look sweet in
those powder blue he's a heck of a
leader yeah a plus all the way I mean
again it was certainly a position of
need for the Los Angeles Chargers the
defense certainly needed some help in
the middle to slow down the run game you
got a guy that's gonna be a physical
presence gonna be able to man up some of
the good pass catching tight ends in
football he is certainly going to
improve that defense altogether that's
secondary Verrett Hayward King and now
we're adding Derwin James he's going to
be the case
I'm Chancellor for the Chargers hey
Chargers you better sell out that
Stadium this year cuz about to be the
lip so we have ourselves a trade Packers
come back up man it better be for
Hendrick the Packers have the Seattle's
pick it's gotta be Landry yeah I mean
I'm not saying like it will be but it
could be they need pass rushers like
crazy so let me ask you so other than
Landry I feel like once we get through
Landry I feel like we've got through our
blue tipz three big drop-off I feel like
once we get through Landry now we're in
the wide receivers at the top we're at
the corners at the top we're at the
offensive linemen at the top and I think
we're Sean Evans is there but I think
between Landry and Evans there was a
pretty large gathers the big board for
you yeah yeah because like I look at
Connor Williams it's it's it depends on
what I'm actually a little surprised
because we're did this pick pick 18 and
I mean all the top ten guys are off
they're all off and and I think durin
was the last falling down guy but Harold
was the last guy that we thought could
possibly be a top ten yeah I really
never bought into him and top ten Oh
only because of the position yeah just
like we see McGlinchey going higher than
we thought
I thought maybe Landry could go higher
because pass rushers are hard to find
that's right I am one of my things I
wrote in my notes for Harold Landry I
wrote 20 through 32 but because of the
position and being light at the position
in the draft yeah you might get over
draft like a lot of my friends in the
like draft industry put gyre Alexander
babe I think Jay Alexander is definitely
a possible as well for Mike swap they
swapped a seventh for a third so the
Seahawks are getting a third big figure
moving down right well no they were
'saying talked about the trade value
chart changing yeah and because they
added the compensatory picks to trade
them so now with more picks I wonder if
they lose a little bit of value but your
final predictions you're going Landry
know you're gonna go joy year did you
just cheat on us no my team look my big
boards been up this whole time I don't
think husband I don't know if I can plug
other it's got Jeter you know this guy
more you think he's cheating I can't
tell alright hold up in final guesses
you're gonna go
you're gonna go joy here yeah cuz that's
what are you going I'm gonna go Landry
I'm gonna go joy here I'm gonna go to
cheater
well you picked you picked wisely to
cheat because it's giant I know Daniel
Jeremiah had this and he knows Green Bay
better than anyone okay it's like when I
see him say like every year whoever he
says Green Bay staking I'm yeah Sims you
this is your I feel like this is your
favorite corner I think overall I I
actually think maybe Mike Hughes is a
little bit better than you actually had
my cues going to the Packers yeah for
Jasmine I love ya I like Jags
girag Zinta better than Denzel Ward I am
a musician excited for this guy because
there needed it they had Kevin King who
they took last year in the second round
but they were lying on Truman Williams
who has not lived up to that one good
year
Quinten Rollins and Josh Hawkins they
need corners as Sims like to say they're
playing Matt Stafford Kirk Cousins and
Mitchell too risky you need corners what
are your grades for junior I'm gonna
give it a B+ I'm going to give it an A+
whoa a little bit about the knee I'm not
a doctor doctor doctor you didn't think
so
like I mean his short area quickness is
great I didn't see like recovery speed
no sir I love how cocky this kid is he
is a dog I love it give him that the
Packers started at 14 they bounced
around and they get a corner that I know
the guys up here really like and when
you run Mike Patton's defense you need
some quarters Matt Miller the value of
getting him trading back and getting
buddy yeah I loved what they did here
moving around the board and not giving
up a ton to come get one of the best
corners left and a guy who can play
inside or outside he has speed he is
aggressive at the line of scrimmage he
can help you out a little bit in the
slot sees the ball well one of my
biggest concerns with him I went to see
him play against Clemson and he was hurt
and it was seems like every time I tried
to Scout him this year he was hurt with
a knee injury that I know some teams
have flagged so his numbers this past
year weren't indicative of the type of
talent he is but I had him 24 on the
board and that's with an injury can
so he's a very good player a phenomenal
football player I've looked at it like
this first of all Green Bay Packers fans
you got Mike Pettine as your defensive
coordinator what's his history Oh New
York Jets what did he have a corner that
could live on an island this guy can
live on an island he can now do creative
things with the rest of his defense he
doesn't necessarily need a pass rusher
he's creative Rex Ryan blitz package so
I look at the gyre Alexander and go man
this guy can match up with any receiver
in football he's got attitude his speed
his short area quickness is as good as
you're gonna find in this whole draft
but asked about junior Alexander his
college coach Bobby Petrino said what
Lamar does for the offense J ear does
for the defense pretty big claim that's
your great I gave it a b-plus like I
said I'm just a little worried about the
knee and I know Krista said he's not a
doctor I'm not either but talking to
people around the league I think there's
a little bit of concern but no the
Packers have been very aggressive I like
what the new front office is done yes I
I definitely do - I've been a plus this
is one of my favorite players in the
draft I think he's better than I think
he's gonna project better than the pros
and Denzel Ward who was a number four
pick I know I might be crazy and I
understand that but he fits what they
needed he's got a super attitude as far
as a corner that's gonna be in your face
and brain attitude the defense yeah he's
a playmaker and let's not forget he
returned he could be one of the best
punt returners than the NFL next year
and I don't know if Trevor Davis was
gonna be that guy but Green Bay moved
around and they got one of the best
corners and some picks to go with
Packers failure Alexander cool I just
saw Jerry Jones on the phone Dallas is
gonna make this a whole spectacle
because they're a bunch of anybody knows
who likes the Cowboys I do it was good
when the Cowboys are good
I like Cowboys I root for Jason Garrett
I like Ezekiel and I chose guy so Dallas
gets rid of Dez yeah and the whole talk
is will they get Calvin Ridley I know
that you like DJ more more than Calvin
Ridley here I did it definitely wider so
for the Cowboys no
remember Sean Evans and Buddy all the
other guy out there they go whole week
play we go defense so I think it's
Layton Vander ish you think that long is
he cute medically okay hands are in the
air I haven't touched never know what
play him a what middle linebacker yeah
and put Jalen at strong what is with
them in white linebackers
I don't know I like that idea well
listen linebacker certainly in need I
mean linebackers are need Jalen with the
nerve damage in his knee okay we're
still not sure he's ever gonna be that
guy why not take Rashad Evans that you
know is a like a guaranteed lock I mean
know if anybody's a guaranteed loss I
mean yeah but I feel like I trust him
more than I do late in Vanda rush I like
him better than Layton Banderas but I'm
I know that there's certainly a lot of
people out there that don't she's such a
great athlete they're not gonna go is
there any chance they go pass rusher
here David Irving and all of his issues
that Marcus Lawrence will be a free
agent after this season Kony Ealy Zoli
being signed on a one-year deal that
link ago pastor but then again I'm just
telling you that they're starting wide
receivers or Cole Beasley Terrence
Williams and Deonte Thompson and Allen
Hurns yeah but I just I am so done with
her going to run the ball and be that
type of team you don't really need well
know you have to have a difference-maker
at one receiver so DJ more because yeah
he's got it you got to do something to
go we have to scare them from putting
eight guys or nine guys in the box all
the time you have to have when when this
offense was really clicking what did
they do
Dez Bryant let out oh it's single
coverage I'll throw to the Dez Bryant oh
you're doubling does will run the ball
it was really that formula so that's
where DJ more makes sense I've seen the
Cameron Sutton kid from I'm not a
Portland Portland sudden from SMU yeah
the other corner all right so what's
your final guess is gonna be mine stone
Evander ish I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
more I'm gonna go more to what do you
think I'm mad you know I don't think
that I don't think it's offense I'm
gonna I'm gonna go with the wild card
here and say Courtland Sutton I think if
I'm wrong it'll be another defender they
were obsessed with Courtland a sudden
that his pro day I mean I really thought
they were gonna be like can you I mean
I'm on that yeah I can we inspect you
fully
I'm shot of it oh so we're gonna play
that game I don't like try to get points
bro trying to get Rashad Evans right now
it's funny as you could tell our set is
here at AT&T Stadium why go to Dallas
when you can chill in New York kids it's
not like 80 and there's barbeque man we
can get you some barbecue here let's go
to Brooklyn what do you think is if you
were their GM what would you do I would
take leighton vander as long as you pass
medically i know everybody's told you
don't feel the same way about Layton no
I do not feel the same way about Layton
especially in that scheme I'm a little
bit skeptical of it I understand the
special scream so tell me the mirror not
marinelli scheme what do they need yeah
I mean its cover to cover three it's a
four times lady Annerose she's a bill I
know but they've never had that big time
middle linebacker they've always gone
for more of the true I think he's laid
up on weald
I think yes yeah I don't know I just I
I'm not in love with the guy overall I
know been hurt a lot yes I don't think
he's plays overall physical like you
said he doesn't is there any chance they
go back to the Michigan well after
getting taco charlton and go Maurice
Hearst I think the the clicker is a
little bit of a problem there guys yeah
and I wouldn't take him in the first
round no I'm just your Lane radius I
know the cowboy is there any chance that
Jason Witten is getting older and
they're gonna go for a heart hurdle for
a goat I think it's way too early this
tight in class is deep so you could give
more Dez person making the picks it's
Jerry Jones you got the copper Jason
garrison next is will McClaren jury is
you know because Dallas is a little like
old Oakland Raiders but I just go for
the past well look like I said before
DeMarcus Lawrence is a free Egypt of the
cheers so is David Irving David Irving
has had plenty of suspension issues the
other thing that's interesting is Zach
Morton and Chad's green or free agents
at the end of the year too and they're
trying to get a deal done with Zack
Martin yes I don't think he's going
anywhere now but that offensive line
sure did fall off quick from - you know
I've been saving like three weeks on the
podcast that this should be late in
vandura so maybe I'm actually to be
upset if it's not what are they just
gonna sit here and let the fanfare go on
for every time Alice are you kidding me
Jerry Jones said they're going out for
me I'm seeing something but I don't want
to come I want a more legitimate person
look can you see me tell us what you're
seeing can you tell us who the
non-legitimate person
it's a white boy supreme late in
Mandarin yes he is the pick that's what
the first one I saw I want one more I
don't call him out for not being a
reputable source who is it I don't know
no one's told me anything I mean I know
that he was way more interesting right
now martavis Bryant just got traded
what martavis Bryant just got traded to
the Raiders for their third round pick
of course they did I was gonna say first
of all the Raiders yeah that's okay
that's so Oakland I mean I can't Darryl
Worley a martavis Bryant put them on the
same team
dude but no think about this Rory Cooper
and martavis Bryant with Jordy Nelson in
the middle that's on Gruden's trying to
do something now yeah I just heard I
look at the positive I'd heard of and
Arash it's bandura his van der s okay
he's good what do you guys think
what are grades on I gave him a hey they
got the corniest linebacker meeting room
in the end I'm just gonna give it a B
Connor okay no you love Layton VIN I did
yeah we had him on the podcast he's a
great athlete he's an upside cast super
super smart swimmer Sean Evans here I
would have okay yes definitely I don't
dislike Layton Vander rush I was not
overwhelmed with his film as a whole I'm
overwhelmed with the prospects of the
athlete and player he can be but your
issue is this people would juice up
games and you'd be like okay he had 15
tackles but like 12 of them were like
how I ever did you watch that organ game
and I want to be what do you mean when
the Red Sea parted and they just ran
into his chest and they had a tackle and
I mean it was nothing
great this is why we're better than TV
TVs gonna make kids clap we're gonna
give you the pic let's do the video the
lagoons
the draft was in Dallas and they need a
linebacker in the middle for Shawn Lee
and the future and they're going late in
van der s here Miller was all over this
kid from Boise State you love him
you're a little bit more questioning
let's start off with the love I said
this was my guy in this strap not my
favorite player not my top-ranked
linebacker this is just my guy an
athlete in the middle of the field could
play weak side backer could play Mike so
good it was let's do a lot of different
things you see here he's asked to go
after the quarterback he was asked to
play up the seam a lot which I think
would be a great fit in their defense I
had him as my 19th overall player he
just went 19th overall to the Dallas
Cowboys
so making me look smart Jerry appreciate
it and I know he's a physical specimen
he's a specimen he really is I mean he
has room to grow as a player in general
and he's gonna get bigger and thicker
and stronger yes when you watch him on
the field he's an incredible athlete can
run sideline to sideline like Jermaine
Edmonds he's gonna be a pain in the butt
to throw around in the middle of the
defense because of his size his length
you saw he'd add a thirty nine and a
half inch vertical so yes he is made to
stop the pass as well but I did I had
questions about some of the things that
I saw at the middle linebacker position
talk about the fact that there were
teams I reported there were five teams
that failed him medically because of a
narrowing in his spine the Cowboys
logins they weren't one of them because
they felt comfortable taking him here so
I gave it an a man I think he is one of
the better players in the class a great
fit for them and just you're never gonna
have to worry about him they have to
worry about so many players on this team
you're never gonna have to work late in
doing J it's K he's watching film right
it's character I get that I do he is a
can't-miss from that standpoint I'm only
going to give this a B though from this
standpoint this guy as a middle
linebacker I'm not necessarily just
excited about it I don't think he just
he doesn't lay the wood he's not the
most physical middle linebacker I've
ever seen he's athletic yes certainly
but I would have rather of them taken
Rashad Evans if they wanted a middle
linebacker I think he was a better
player at the position that's why I give
it a big I think sometimes Jerry loves a
story this is a man that played
eight-man football and grew up in a town
in Idaho that had a population of 400
and now he's wearing a star on his
helmet no matter what to hell of a story
leighton van Dhiresh the future at
middle line
the Dallas Cowboys for weak sides
okay so 20 Detroit has to go even in
jail we'll pick we're on anymore happens
to be format Patricia know that Patricia
could go corner here yeah I thought it
could be corner two but what else what
else did you say I thought it would be
here Landry I'll tell you what the
reason how our Landry makes a lot of
sense a lot of their pass rushers are up
for free agency next year whether it's
Ezekiel ants all those guys also they
haven't been great at getting after the
quarterback in recent years 20th and
sacks last year zekiel ants as a free
agent carry hiders gonna be a free agent
but I know I agree with Sims here
Patricia running that that Patriots
defense they they need corners and right
now it's Darius slay and then he's
paired with Nevin Lawson so I don't know
so I could see if I really don't let's
go to your big board here Harold Landry
makes the most noise makes no sense I
liked Connor Williams I know there's
some talking he might be a guard I think
he could play tackle I expect we'll hear
his name you get called tonight but
Harold Landry is definitely up there if
they go corner Josh Jackson's the best
on my board Mike Hughes I just worry
about two all field a little yeah I mean
I know I don't know I know a little bit
of the other stories of Mike Hughes but
Mike Hughes man just from pure on the
field talent I mean he was my favorite
corner in the draft I really loved his
ability to jam people of the line of
scrimmage his speed he played weight
faster than his four or five speed he
will be the best punt returner in
football next I was looking over the
Lions roster yeah I love what they've
done at linebacker I'm this offseason
Jared Davis was a homerun pick and you
put Christian Jones and Devon Canard
next to it yes this is a Lions team that
would get torched by running backs out
of the backfield
every time I watched and now look at
those guys in the middle yeah speed and
speed right LeGarrette Blount I sold
with the Eagles he's not a feature back
but he's gonna give the hard-nosed
running that Detroit hasn't had because
guess what they were in rushing last
year Sims last like they are every
frickin year but said but but Matthew
Stafford is not very good
oh I heard Carson Palmer on Leavitt ARDS
saying they said what quarterback do you
think has been hurt by a situation than
most it's Matt Stafford yeah so I think
that their offense is pretty good I
think that the offensive line I don't
know if there's anyone worthy to maybe
help them out with guard play but to me
it's Landry or a coroner
and it depends which corner they want
it's her gut telling you my God would
tell me they would like a Mike Hughes
that would be that kind of place you see
him as a as an island type of climate he
could be like a better version of Malcom
Butler that he had so then you got
Darius lay on one side that could be you
know his Stephon Gilmore and Josh
Jackson's a lot like Malcom Butler but
that will be we'll talk about that in
the second round when he Connor I know
the pick is gonna be in so you're gonna
give it to assume but what's your
prediction man that's how it Landry is
too good to pass up here that's my
thought process I want to ask Sims is
Patricia a guy that says we need as many
corners as possible because New England
operates them yeah I know I do think
that he is along those lines that we're
up Quinn the GN well yeah I do think
there are along the lines that they want
two corners they can trust a man to make
sure I know I know
we got the pitch saber and it's not
Harold Landry and it's not corner it's
my guy Frank Ragna oh there you go there
are offensive linemen from Arkansas okay
put a left guard so now the offensive
line will be Ricky Wagner TJ Lang Graham
Glasgow your man rag now and then Taylor
Decker that's amazing it's a really good
glass guys a better guard than he will
be a center so that's great Swanson was
hurt a spot that they needed why do you
like I disguise so much Connor he's a
powerhouse and absolute powerhouse you
talk about the best anchor on the
interior line I mean I'm talking not as
good as Quentin Nelson but he's the next
guy he's in that Willie Hernandez
powerhouse mode they can open up the
wrong game at both levels and he doesn't
get beat as a pass protector he doesn't
his quarterback is never put in the dirt
when this guy isn't you know playing now
the problem was he lost his entire
season after October and that's what
this reminds me of this reminds me of
when the Patriots took Logan Mankins
yeah and we were looking at different
spots and they took Logan Mankins and he
anchored that line it also kind of
reminds me when Dallas took Travis
Frederick where it's like man I said her
now yeah but I think we're past that era
well tell me about the medicals of this
guy I don't know that he I think he's a
better guard than he is Center you do
yeah I think he's so physical so that's
Robert probably
but you're right the medicals are an
issue what was a foot injury this year
Connor I'm pulling my notes up the foot
injury for sure yeah he missed the whole
year great right he couldn't eat
couldn't do the Senior Bowl yes you know
not much at the combine I suffered a
seizure how do you guys dry left ankle
injury in October he tore every ligament
and required surgery is serious yeah
yeah yeah and that's why I actually had
him low I had an early round to grade on
him and it was because of injury stuff
and I
I really thought Billy price from Ohio
State was better I thought James Daniels
from Iowa was better a - yeah I'll give
it a b-minus I don't know this kid is
damn impressive when you watch the film
he is we watch this yeah because I'd
only really watched like a POA tape
because I was like I don't think this
guy's gonna go in the first round he
didn't play last year so yes I did have
to go back and it's impressive I know
we're gonna get out of this but look we
still got Lamar Jackson no wide
receivers have been taken Y had heard
receivers weren't gonna go until if now
Bengals might take one Patriots might
think yeah oh man
okay all right so we're gonna do Frank
rag now the new interior lineman for the
Detroit Lions
if you're a Detroit Lions fan you know a
few things and one of them is we haven't
helped out Matt Stafford nearly enough
we've been investing in first round
offensive lineman Taylor Decker's one of
them and now Frank rag now is gonna
enter the center kid from Arkansas not
everyone saw him play because right hurt
but what did you see when you watch the
film yeah I mean I loved his versatility
he started a left guard also played some
center he was a team captain for
Arkansas one of the things that you know
the Patriots guys like Quinn and
Patricia love now in Detroit
excellent athletic testing at the pro
day ideal size at 65 312 long arms at
three at 33 and an eighth scheme
versatile one of the toughest guys in
the entire draft as well he finishes he
has that right mentality and before he
got hurt this year 33 games started I
had him early round two because of an
injury though that cost him almost the
entire season
yeah the injuries scary but man the
film's not the films gonna be scary for
defenders he's phenomenal he is probably
the best Center in the draft for me I
mean again to be 65 312 pounds have
those arms but the athlete he is at the
position you got to be twitchy to be a
center if you want to block the Fletcher
Cox in the air in Donnell's of the world
while also snapping the football right
you got to think about that for a second
his ability to get to the second level
and then Miller talked about his anchor
and pass protection everything man he is
he has Pro Bowl potential as a center
low so the Lions are trying to do with
the Patriots right they got Bob Quinn
they got electrician who's working with
the Patriots right now Bret Bielema yeah
that's right I feel like the Lions kind
of stole this offensive lineman that
Bielema coach they know what's good what
grade do you give I gave it a b-minus
and the only reason it's not because I
don't like Frank rag no I just like
Billy price from Ohio State and James
Daniels from Iowa better I understand
the scheme fit he's probably a little
bit better at point of attack in the
power run game but a little bit of a
reach hey listen I get that I this is
the best Center for me the other guys
you're talking about are extremely good
I'm going to give this an a-minus first
of all hey you're past protecting your
franchise in the quarterback and listen
I don't care who's that running back
with some of the offensive lines they
put out there in the past it doesn't
matter you're not gonna run anywhere
there's no holes
Ragna is gonna bring them attitude okay
and he's extremely
in all phases the football game and if
they had to move into guard they could
do that it's a good bet troit lives were
the worst team in the NFL last year of
rushing they finally are put in
offensive line in front of staffer and
the boy the Lions are coming watch out
in the NFC North Bengal they were gonna
take him really
that was something the Bengals are a
Landry spot no I think they'll take
Daniels or price you think they've like
been so on it all like almost said of
proof that was it would have been bad I
don't know your oh gosh so Connor let's
get this pick baby you're on to it cuz
it's Billy price yeah they were gonna
take rack no no will he be ready for
camp yeah I talked to him a couple days
ago he's gonna be good okay yeah and
this is another Ohio State kid that got
to stay in the state of Ohio yeah I love
Billy price man yeah it's pretty it's
you look at this offensive line they got
Courtney Glen at left tackle they got
Clinton bowling at left guard Jake
Fisher's gonna have to figure it out a
right tackle their centers TJ Johnson
and their right guard was Trey Hopkins
they need interior offensive line
Bradley
Connor I'm gonna give this a name Lamar
Jackson to the Ravens next pick I mean
are we I'm gonna give it an Harold
Landry to the Ravens at 22 actually is
incredible I'm gonna give it an A as
well you're hypothesizing urine a yeah
Billy you're an a-plus yeah cool you
didn't just that Pig didn't happen here
no no I'm just thinking we did a video
the other day where Simpson Harold
Landry could be the next terrell suggs
and now he's falling to the Ravens at 22
injuries for him are obviously a concern
and that's why he's still there all
right we're gonna do Billy price the
true center going to the Cincinnati
Bengals
Cincinnati Bengals have been drafted a
lot of offensive lime in the last few
years but they haven't really seemed to
hit but I'll tell you the excitement
just coming off of this guy or happy
eating this might be the one Billy price
Ohio State staying in the same plug and
play he could play guard for you you
could play Center was a team captain
weight room freak great player a
finisher on the field you said he could
play right guard he could pull he can
trap he could get to the second level
and man he will put some defenders in
the dirt first team all-american a
little old already 23 years old since
this kid pop off the film for what he
does he pops off the film he's 6 for 312
pounds he's a stout Center he's a little
different than like a frac Frank rag
know who got drafted out of Arkansas but
regardless he's phenomenal in the run
game and with that strength and a great
lower half body that I like you're not
gonna overpower this guy he can play
center he can play guard whatever it may
be I saw Alex Mack here okay and he's
one of the most athletic best senators
the exactly right I don't think there's
gonna be a scheme or a matchup on the
defensive line that's ever gonna be a
problem for Billy price if you tell me
that you have an Ohio State offensive
lineman that played all four years and
won the Rimington Trophy yeah it's kind
of a solid guy the only reason he's
still here is because a torn peck
suffered in training so that's why is he
fell a little bit but I saw him as a
Ryan Kelly type player and anyone who
remembers our draft when Ryan Kelly came
out of Alabama
I loved that kid knew this guy named
Billy price I put a first-round grade on
him an a-plus I put a first-round grade
on him in September and put my pin down
just about scouting him yeah I give it a
I mean this is a position of need for
the Cincinnati Bengals and this guy is a
hell of a player like I said he can he
he's got quicks to match up with the
quick D tackles he's got the power to
match up against the bigger defensive
tackles the only negative about the guy
I wrote is falls off blocks sometimes
only because he's trying to kill people
he literally has to dial it back into
here but that's the kind of guy I like I
like that too Urban Meyer when asked
about him said I'm deeply indebted for
his leadership and play well guess what
that's pretty good that's pretty good
since I need bangles they got their
interior lineman for a very long time
we have ourselves a trade another one
the Ravens have traded back to the
Tennessee Titans they're gonna take care
of Landry
oh man yeah Wow and they need a pass
rush or badly what do you think the
agree with him Connor uh-oh I think it's
rashon Evans
oh I'd be great with that too I think
when you look at Vrabel he I mean the
way Evans I think Bray Ville wanted van
Dhiresh and now he's gonna get Evans and
Evans takes all other hurt I better any
no I don't know yeah I heard the Titans
failed him ah a lot of medical yeah the
medical issue so if you look at the pass
rushers right now Brian Iraq Poe and
Derek Morgan
yeah both free agents after this and
both getting a little older
middle linebacker they did lose Avery
Williamson yeah and there is kind of a
hole there right now it's Nate Palmer
and Wesley Woodyard right where they got
Dean Pease and Rashad Evans they're Sean
Evans is CJ Mosley so but the question
is if you're Dean Pease do you want
Terrell Suggs or CJ Mosley yeah Harold
Landry or Rashad Evans yeah I know where
is there a part of you they don't need a
quarter I just wonder it last year
Harold Landry film was hurting him like
you know you listen we know he wasn't a
hundred percent healthy but there's a
number of coaches that look at me when I
say things like that they go well yeah
but does he open so if he ever gonna be
the same guy that we saw from junior
year or whatever imagine what variables
Titans just jump New England yeah I know
what he would have been interested in
Landry to or Rashad Evans they both they
might have something that they're
interested in and they want me to count
on linebacker in the country last year
they drool to myself good we're at that
point of the draft at that point we're
sitting I've always been holding my pee
for three hours then where I held it it
got bad and now we're right in that
middle you know we're talking about I
gotta go yeah all right so Titans what's
your prediction this one I really don't
fight is Landry
you're gonna guess Landry I mean I just
I don't know if I'm gonna go because of
what you're saying about the Patriots I
feel like the Patriots wonder where Sean
Evans I feel like they're jumping up and
take Evans I would be as a person who
wants to live in Nashville as soon as
possible and be really I love Nashville
you're a cowboy hat but what do you say
what was your guess he's guessing Landry
I'm guessing Evans what are you guessing
I'm gonna go Evans as well what do you
going here Connor I'm going Evans I'm
sticking it up so in the terrain
Tennessee gave up a 4th and they got
back a 6 I'm shocked at the little
amount of pics that it's taking to move
up four or five spots I got the pic all
right Connor lay the wood humble brag I
was right it's not Evan that's a yeah
wow that was the first time that you
were wrong Miller
no I've been wrong with the first day
must have not texted him the answer that
had tried to get him there was
calculated move to jump new wing I think
it was we talked every Mach I saw had
the Patriots taking Rashad Evans at 23
the biggest giveaway for me that the
Patriots liked Mershon Evans was mike
Mayock stop hundred lists mike Mayock
talks to Bill Belichick bill straightens
him out on who where he should rank
players and where Sean Evans was like
pick number 30 I was the 13th best
player in the draft does I go up so bill
likes Rashad Evans huh I mean I was a
giveaway it's very interesting that they
take rag now the center and Rashad Evans
and I feel like the Patriots like both
of those guys without a doubt yes well
it's still it's a GM that came from New
England John Robinson I'm gonna give
this an a yeah same here man we're Sean
Evans go into a mic for able team that
made the playoffs last year and what's
really funny is what position did the
Patriots absolutely destroy in that game
line back yes we left that game when we
went the linebackers were just talking
to each other because they had no idea
right and Rashad Evans is a second-team
all-sec captain of alabama or ready to
go day one exactly he's awesome man he's
so much more than Avery Williams he
could play he can play off the edge even
man you're gonna be interesting he is
like yeah he's a he's a he's a really
impressive football player hey hey give
me camera five real quick the Patriots
are on the clock
Lamar Jackson is there is he the next
town Brady
at the Cardinal noise gisla large Expo
John Evans there's a good pic by the
Cardinals don't make that kind of noise
I was horrible that's a dollar at the
bird feeder as a dolphin I think I'm
right
dolphins Cardinals the Titans were
picking behind the Patriots and then
they weren't maybe they knew a little
something and maybe Vrabel had his eyes
on a linebacker that loves him rashon
evans alabama this guy just makes so
much sense yeah and he makes so many
plays he was my number 20 player overall
so a great value for the Tennessee
Titans he could play in the middle of
the field he could play coming off the
edge he's a do adult linebacker and he
is a twitch dub version of what we're
used to from Alabama and I know people
who liked him better than Rueben foster
when you put it all together because
there's no off field he's just as safe
as they come at linebacker and rebels
probably saw a little bit of himself in
this guy because he really can be a
difference maker weak side strong side
Mike anywhere you put him this is a
Titans team that was second in the NFC
AFC South they went to the playoffs can
this guy take him to the next step yeah
he certainly can he's a player that has
zero weakness I mean and he can do
anything middle linebacker oh you wanted
to play outside linebacker for a game
whatever it may be he's gonna be able to
do that if you want to put him in and
rush him off the edge a little bit he
did that at Alabama as well but he's a
true middle linebacker who can run
sideline to sideline he's been coached
well he's gonna understand this scheme
Dean piece three four type of scheme and
he's gonna be phenomenal and past
coverage as well I was really impressed
with the kid man he's athletic he can
get off blocks he's physical like I said
there's no weakness to him at all so
what grade do you give him now I give it
an A I think he is a plug-and-play
starter and we're seeing Mike Vrabel
really put his stamp on this team the
toughness that they he wants on defense
Evans is smart he's athletic I compared
him to Alec Ogletree I think he could be
a little better than that because he's
so explosive yeah I see that Alec Cole
the tree I'm giving a as well I mean
this was a huge position of need for a
team that's coached by an ex middle
linebacker
that played in this similar scheme so he
understands what this is all about Evans
I looked at it Dean peas a deep D
coordinator of the gari I go
this is CJ Mosley who he had in
Baltimore is this kind of player he
could be in a few Pro Bowl certainly the
Titans lost Sylvester Williams Avery
Williamson and Bryce McCain and they got
Bennie Logan Rashad Evans and Malcom
Butler yet that Titans are a lot better
yeah and they made the playoffs last
year for Sean Evans Manning the middle
for years to come any chance they take I
just still can't believe I'm looking at
number one Baker Mayfield it's popping
up with a sign that the Browns left with
Baker Mayfield and Denzel wort and they
could have had say quad and Berkeley and
Josh Allen like or or sand Arnold and
say or Bradley Chubb and they left with
Baker Mayfield and Denzel Ward it's just
sometimes it doesn't matter where the
numbers are yeah just got to look at the
players you got and you get to
undersized guys it's interesting it is
alright we're gonna go to Connor here
first
what is your Patriots prediction man I
think Josh Jackson you think Josh
Jackson they definitely need think
they'll look for a corner I think
they'll look for a guy with ball skills
and length I mean he's got the perfect
bill like what about Harold Landry but
guys I'm just gonna say this with the
Josh Jackson he doesn't play man-to-man
I know that would be my one issue
everything Patriots that play a lot of
mana man yeah that would be my one issue
with that it's probably why we've seen
him slide further than a lot of people I
think you do specific they you know this
day and age the way the league is right
now you know with the rules the way they
are if you can't play to man-to-man on
third and six or less you're gonna be in
deep trap Andy is there any chance that
the the Patriots knowing that Gronk
could retire soon go ahead and Hurst
here I like it leaders okay it certainly
could fit yes there was there any chance
that they lost Nate's older they go at
Connor Williams here tackle out of Texas
he doesn't seem to fit them very well I
mean I don't know he's a super athlete
you got Dante's car Nicki I don't know
you know I don't know I don't know if
he'd be their type of tackle they they
want to know what I thought they won the
inter thought attack I'm right
they want cold Miller's Nate soldiers
they want you know Sebastian volmers
guys that are six eight Connor Williams
is like six five one three fifteen
hundred three hundred right yeah is
there any chance they go at Aven Brian
here gosh he would fit what they want to
do they load it up in free agency though
on the d-line rate did get dementia and
in their day I'm Malcolm Brown they have
Adrienne Claiborne who I think that's
what Ava and Brian what kind of be that
role I will say though Danny Shelton
Malcolm Brown both free agents after the
year Trey flowers is a free agent of the
year and a girl and jury is sitting I
know and this is New England which is
scouts Boston all the time I mean
they're all over boss and it could be
maybe Lamar Jackson he's not on the
phone he's all of them it's he's looking
around he has no idea what he's like I
don't know I never bought that talk so
if we're gonna go the Patriots right now
let's say they go corner Panthers are
next Calvin Ridley falling into their
lap then the Ravens come back at 25
that's where I think the more that could
be that's probably listen all they got
to do they can't they can't go farther
than 29 the Ravens though cuz the
Jacksonville gets Lamar Jackson the Jack
the Jags I was the Jaguars to trade up
get Lamar just many people says he
doesn't that's what we reckon the NFL
know what that sound means that means
we're going to the bulging by I love
this line it is what was James day and I
love this player it's pregnant Isaiah
when I say okay I got a guy that you
know he's like you said Sims n Miller
this could be a Pro Bowl guard right
well I've talked to some teams that do
think you can do sensible tackle yeah I
see it I'd be nice left tackle I don't
think he will I think the guys you know
again they have guys on the roster
Marcus cannon we're missing the other
guy captain Antonio Garcia more Antonio
Garcia
they got Jason he he check Mason that's
actually go I compare him to I mean that
would be an unbelievable run game guard
combo I mean this kids a shock Mason
Isiah win Isiah win is
is yeah Jody was kind of getting knocked
around well so maybe there uh Tony did
have issues you're right about that we
can't forget that Tony had issues during
the year he was really a liability
through most of the years he did not
play up to the ability I liked chef
Mason but you guys never had the Super
Bowl lightly right thinner let's check
Mason get by uh Brandon Graham what do
you think on greats guys Oh
let's give it let me just think of what
else were they really doing this many
interior offensive linemen going in a
row here Frank rag now 20 Billy price at
21 as a win at 23 we're in Iran ago a -
Connor oh I'm gonna be with myself guard
grades again it's off great yeah
Sims you'll love this he was the number
one offensive line recruit in the state
of Florida means you know I like me man
and now we have it's interesting so
don't use it he's listed so you guys
talked about wanting a Neanderthal he's
a six to tackle yeah I know that's why I
don't think he's a tackle I think he
will be moved to guard I really know who
do they put you're gonna get throw me
out of there they're gonna get through D
out of there let a drian waddle and
cannon and and really the guy that we
were just talking about Garcia they love
Garcia really he had medical issues but
they love him that'll be their interior
with David Andrews I think it'd be David
Andrews Shaq Mason and Isaiah win yeah
and then where do they put in Garcia
Garcia is gonna be a tackle tackle he's
66 he's their guy guess what Tom Brady's
protected for these last waning years
let's do Isaiah win to the Patriots this
is by the way the pick they got in the
Brandon cooks trade
the Patriots are really good at
addressing important positions they got
the 23rd pick from trading brain and
cooks they didn't need the receiver but
they turn that into Isaiah win a
punishing Center offensive lineman
that's gonna go there the guard and now
sudden this Patriots lines looking
pretty dogs it does look pretty good and
I had I say a win ranked number 29
overall played left tackle at Georgia
freakishly long arms great in the run
game I think he does kick inside to left
guard for the Patriots run James don't
look better past protections don't look
better and and he is a dude anytime you
talk to coaches of Georgia they raved
about team first good athlete very
productive plan left tackle so I like
this pick a lot and the value definitely
was there especially after we saw guys
like where Sean Evans late vander rush
come right off the board yeah well you
know Patriots better than a lot of
people what do you think about him in
that Cisco I think he fits the system I
don't think there's any way he plays
left tackle like I think they could get
away with it if they needed to through
injury but this guy is a prototypical
guard I just don't think he's a big
enough human for them to put him in that
tackle knowing the Patriots scouting
system but man the guy is unbelievable
you want to talk about a road grader in
the run game he can move people out of
the way in fact his negative is really
that he's like a little too aggressive
like we've talked about with other
offensive linemen where he falls off but
yes it's like a coal heo Somali but not
as big I wrote a lot like a lay out Lyle
Collins who plays on the Dallas Cowboys
but extremely impressed with this guy
they should be able to do all the
spatial things that the Patriots need
the screens all that stuff type the wide
receiver screens he's gonna be able to
get out there and block and lead the way
great for him at 23 yeah I gave it a B+
I think he can play guard I think you
could play Center think you can get him
in a lot of different spots so it is a
smart pick and I'm often critical of
Bill Belichick the general manager yeah
he got this one right yeah I know I mean
Bill Belichick the general manager gets
saved by Bill Belichick the coach a lot
I'm going to give this an a though
because this offensive line a - sorry
this offensive line was below average
last year it just was not good enough
Tom Brady got hit way too much the run
game was inconsistent this is gonna give
them a true you know bonafide legit
top-tier guard in the middle that's
gonna help out in a lot of ways they're
improving
: good for that lost soldier they lost
cavern plumbing and don't forget this
we're talking bout parinama Shack mason
Shack Masons a free agent after this
year right so it could be stocking up it
could also be inventory Isaiah win the
pick for the Patriots number 23 Calvin
Ridley hundred percent twenty four I
mean that's what I would think I could
see corner as well do this I know they
just gave him a mini extension do they
start to look Greg Olson I know like hey
Hearst is right now got hurt I know I
know
oh I've thought about all those and the
corner thing I thought - I just go damn
you know we don't see it about four
corners right they don't really seem to
do that so her knee does a little more
than yeah he probably does more than the
past regime sure is their corners men
are James Bradbury
Kevon Seymour captain Marlon corn elder
I would just take an Isaiah Oliver here
and be done with it but you would take
him over one of these wide receivers
because right now these are the starting
libraries and the receivers you want
Carolina Panthers Torrey Smith Devin
Funchess Tamir bird Russell Shepherd
Curtis Samuel Jarius right I mean I
didn't hear the Panthers tweeted their
training from the team account yeah I
just saw it
Oh people suck on Twitter never mind all
right how about these guys Harold Landry
still somehow on the board we're
thinking this is because of his last
year yeah just the injury maybe there's
something more medical to it then we
don't know part well let me ask you this
Julius Peppers getting up there in age
Mario Edison not really a pass rusher I
don't know where the pass rush is coming
is there any chance that maybe Harold
Landry's the guy no I don't know like
were you thinking you heard Calvin
Ridley I I didn't hear it I just think
that makes a lot of sense
Seaford they need a safe pick and
receiver they got to give Cam Newton
some weapons at some I actually agree
you know I mean he's a safe pick he's
not the most explosive he's not the best
but he's gonna be polished ready to be
all good about a runner at the corner to
where you could get a corner and run I
exact there's no reason that a team with
Cam Newton a quarterback should have
been 28th in the NFL in passing offense
I know there's gonna be a ding and I
know we're going to Conor we have a
little rule at bleacher report at the
NFL desk where if you get chaps or
fooled you have to wear the hat you have
to wear the hat and Miller again but
Miller just got I did he got played so
bring me the Hat he's got gosh it's good
hog by I don't know some idiot on
Twitter so yeah if you believe Twitter
rumors this happened to me a few years
ago we've all been adjusting you my
camera there all right so we got the pig
look-alike Bob the baby don't look at
the TV Sims all right it's a wide
receiver
DJ more it's not Calvin Ridley it's DJ
more DJ more for that Maryland I love it
do I take this I just made money betting
on DJ more - yes what do you think it
for grade
I'll give it a B how dare you dare he
took the hat off well I have to do a
real video are you gonna do it in the
video I don't know what the rule is no
do it after the video yeah forget the
video goes on BR the VR app if you don't
have it you're a loser that's the model
right or if you believe people what I
can't be if you have the VR app use you
like traditional networks telling you
what to believe and you're not a
free-thinking independent individual and
you should probably go eat McDonald's
because it's finally a guy for Cam
Newton that can make a play with the
ball in his hands
definitely yeah I'm just glad that he's
got a weapon around him he from Maryland
Philadelphia oh yeah that's right he is
from Philadelphia but he's mean the I
think he's it's the athlete that excites
me here that's what really excites me I
mean and also look Calvin released 23 DG
Morse 21 yeah I don't like older guys
excelling against young kids in college
it's my Kelvin Benjamin indeed and
Calvin Ridley he's older and he can't do
the things DJ Morecambe of the bozos you
watched one play of DJ Moore and you
said I like him better than
remember that yeah you pulled up the
film and said he just did something that
Calvin really didn't I never saw him do
right exactly right they got a little
Steve Smith here that's right it's a
good way the press say it awesome let's
do a video there's no reason that a team
with Cam Newton should be 28th and
passing offense and I'll tell you what
they've lost Kelvin Benjamin over the
years they've been relying on people
like Curtis Samuel no more DJ Moore is
what we call an explosive athlete 21
year old out of Maryland what are they
getting at a pick number 25 I I said
right before we started filming they're
getting a little Steve Smith here I mean
he's aggressive with the ball in his
hands he's a powerful runner in the open
field he's an elite player after the
catch I think the best in this class
he'd wins a ball in his hands he does
his burst is above average he can run
past coverage he has a thick frame on a
511 body my biggest concerns with him
where I thought his routes were really
lazy at times and he was probably
quicker than fast but run some slants
dude make make life easy for Cam Newton
very productive I do like him a lot yeah
listen I think those problems are like
Sean Davis of we saw a few years ago to
Marilyn it's more coaching than the
athlete I have no pride and had a six
five six nine five three cone drill if
somebody teaches him how to run routes
he's gonna do it this guy has superstar
traits he is numbers I mean they're
phenomenal with the ball in his hand he
is the best receiver in the draft it's
not even close I'll say this for a guy
that's six foot two he is unbelievable
in the 50/50 ball throwing back
shoulders he just plucks the ball out of
the air he has an attitude I like I look
at him like Percy Harvin he played
running back in Maryland - he's Percy
Harvin ish except I think he's a better
route or a better wide receiver than
Percy Harvin was coming out of four or
what you crazy foul no I gave it a B I
like him a lot as a player I think again
he is an explosive route runner he's
gonna help Cam Newton I liked Calvin
Ridley a little better but I get go with
the younger guy because they are pretty
similar I had an early ran too great on
him so to get him here where they did it
24 is a pretty good value yeah okay I'm
gonna go a plus here I mean this is
there you go yeah I know we're different
year these Mariners gonna like well this
is one of my man crushes of the draft
this is one of my favorite players in
the whole a drop yes I do think they're
gonna they're gonna be able
use him in so many different ways you
know think about him almost like a Tyree
kilij but a little bit bigger of a man
the acceleration on this kid just catch
the ball and that goes yeah double moves
and it's a north turner double move it's
like when I'm telling you the guy has a
chance to be a superstar solving those
highlights he was rocking the one at
Maryland you know he got it from Stefon
Diggs I don't know could be something he
might be the number one receiver for the
Carolina Panthers next season Josh
Hendricks didn't give him one bendrix
over here going Maryland dog this is
amazing Ravens are up josh is like I'll
probably leave after pick five Ravens is
this gonna be Lamar Jackson or Harold
Landry I know
get your next terrell suggs or your
kristen a close of this pic I feel like
edges yeah like the Bowser Tim Williams
right Tim Williams Show knows if he's
just he'll I know what happens I'm gonna
neat and Jolly Ranchers ourselves a
Darius Smith they have Korea Brent Urban
is a Darius Smith Terrell Suggs all free
agents after this right so it's kind of
coming to an end with some of the right
herbs not even a real pastor sure he's a
fine I'm just talking about guys that
might I mean Carl Davis is coming up on
the contract but Bryan would make sense
if there's a wife definitely make sense
Haven Bryan looks like a raven yeah yeah
he would he's not like the bird but like
some guy that shite in makes them yeah
yeah I'll be honest that max Williams
guy hasn't really done anything this to
be hidden her this is the Ravens are a
team that you look at their roster and
their secondary is finally set like
their secondary sucks for years and now
it's good but now the rest of their team
has fallen apart so the question is do
you go with the edge rusher or do you
completely change the franchise and go
Lamar guys there is definite legit love
for Lamar Jackson on this thing sign
we're talking about RG 3 so he's
probably gonna take of early because
he's from Alabama Alabama well no but
the possibility spent no no it's not
Willie send it right you're right
they're not going wide receiver
I'm not
few times where I get to tell Sims he's
wrong and feel and I'm looking at Lamar
he's not on the phone so damn hey you
know what
if Lamar Lamar could go to the see
Steelers at 28 where the Jaguars at 29
and I'm loving life yes
Lamar Jackson on the Jaguars is the best
thing for the Simpson left go bug yes it
is selfishly it is the best thing it's
the best this would be one of the best
places for Lamar Jack's Ryan it's gonna
go put the hat back on okay give me the
damn hat I fall for it yeah I know it's
a huge orange hat I feel like on New
York City Vicki watch out here there's a
crane over the top be careful my dad
would be so proud
finally the Ravens are under
construction yeah it's better than the
shaped head that was gonna do a quick
volume soon we go to a commercial break
yeah so I'm seeing one but not buying
into it just yo Connor tell us can you
tell us it'll it'll surprise you yeah
well it's a good football player but
it'll still surprise okay okay John Ben
defense yep well look at my big board oh
this is your best impersonation see
that's why I didn't trust it are we
right about any line I'm getting some
really now it's offense I'm ignoring the
hand they pick you do look like you're
like you know like I count from
Transylvania that has a raven stuck up
in the tower
all right the message it was not defense
that person was wrong I should wear the
hat okay you good I think it's time it's
Hayden Hearst it's a nice williams train
is out of here I just want to give a
shout out to John quark who lost a bet
to me because he thought max was gonna
be good you're an idiot
Wow almost a so you're gonna draft at
old people this kid's gonna be 25 as a
rookie
Heena well I hope he doesn't get the
yips hole he had the yips he was a minor
league baseball player he got a big old
contract
for the Pirates organization his story
is great but he comes out there he's a
heck of a tight end yeah really is
he's soul raids we make fun of his oh
I'll give it a B+ damn so does this mean
that Harold Lane is just gonna fall to
the Falcons I'm gonna give it an egg
Conner oh absolutely
Oh absence of TISS grades I've ever
given this year yeah I think the number
one overall pick was your my meanness
we're meanness harsh is great they
didn't hate Oklahoma what heck did you
make it boomer sooner
Oh what grade did you give here I'm even
know what that means
we got a a from Simms and a b-plus from
Miller it's it's I don't really know
either it's all right let's do it Haden
Hearst I got respect for you though I'm
in there huh oh you Hall of Fame more
than the Lu players getting sacked the
Roy Williams hits everywhere damn guy
a baseball prodigy with a 95
mile-per-hour fastball is going to
Baltimore an inning to the Orioles it's
to the Ravens Hayden her South Carolina
tight end they need another weapon out
there they try to find one a Max
Williams wasn't the guy what are they
getting in Hayden her I think they're
getting a three down tied and someone
who is fierce after they catch like you
said a little bit of an older prospect
but he can dominate up the seam like we
see here and I I think there's still
some potential that he can tap into
because he's learning the intricacies of
the position he'll block for you I think
he's more of an h-back than a true
inline tight in so you're gonna move him
around get him out in space where he can
just go be an athlete make plays so we
had heard all along they were gonna go
pass catch her whether it was receiver
her tight end and they get an upside
prospect here yeah I love this kid I
really do I mean I was just pleasantly
pleasantly surprised when I watched him
I meant film first of all he can do
everything Miller's right I mean really
he can be traditional tight end he could
be H back he can line up at fullback he
can line up a slot receiver he will try
to kill you when he blocks you that's
what I like about him he is fearless
blocker that fits what the Baltimore
Ravens want to do they want to be a
balanced football team but yes he's a
good route runner he's a good athlete
he's very good with the ball in his hand
left go I mean they throw him shuffle
passes they give him speed sweeps in
South Carolina and he makes things
happen with the ball in his hand Marty
morning wag the rose he has always been
a guy that likes that athletic tight end
and this is a team I mentioned max
Williams he's a free agent after this
year maybe it's time to move on you
think about grade wise no I gave it a B+
I do like him a lot I think he can play
any of those tight end alignments that
you can envision for him and he is still
getting better so you get the best three
down tight end in this entire class
they're gonna try to help Joe Flacco out
I'm glad they didn't go quarterback here
I want to see them load up they have a
good defense yeah they've paid some
receivers let's see what they can good I
hear that all that I think I'm given an
a Hayden Hurst I mean this is a position
of need for the Baltimore Ravens I mean
of course yes they want to run the ball
they want to be aggressive down the
middle of the field with Joe Flacco so
he fits it there's nothing not to like
about this kid I think he's really kind
of a can't-miss prospect altogether I
looked at him and I said he's very much
like Dallas Clark to me hmm
Peyton Manning's old teammate that's
what
looked at it as like and hopefully he
can turn to turn that out Hayden her
South Carolina athlete at tight ad I'm
gonna try and open up the middle for Joe
Flacco and the Ravens
all right the pick is in for the Falcons
I'm gonna go with Miller I think it
Steve and Brian I mean I feel like this
is like made for them the easiest pick
ever should be you agreeing with us
Connor I know the pick so it's ruined I
would have said tape and Brian oh no
it's not it is not done they're going
Howard Landry already half they're not
going Harald Lane all right hold on I
guess Alice got hurt oh yeah
they are now going all right I'm gonna
say that they're actually going James
Daniels they are not going James in
although I do like that pick Thank You
having great they're going Calvin Ridley
they are oh well interesting Leo what
the hell was that whole thing I don't
know I'm just glad I know that naked all
of his social media and they were like
he's leaving Atlanta I don't know I know
maybe it's the fact that they have
Mohamed Sanu Justin Hardy and Justin
Hardy hasn't really turned into anything
right and maybe they're blaming
sarkeesian's lack of offensive
creativity on the lack of wide receiver
well and sinew is limited in some of the
things he can do as well we'll say this
though Nick Saban went to Alabama and
got three wide receivers to go in the
first round Julio Jones Amari Cooper and
now Calvin Ridley and two of them are on
the same team Calvin Ridley
yeah and Julio Jones daily dope yeah
that is pretty dope Adam Schefter
tweeted one of the greatest moments in
NFL draft history is coming up soon
don't want to miss it will be memorable
well that's the Jaguars taking Lamar
Jackson or or it's the chicken Griffin
in the first round
Wow I love them on the Seahawks with his
brother alright so Calvin Ridley though
what is your grade for getting him it I
give it an A+ A+ you know Calvin really
is crying on TV that's nice what do you
think it's Sims what your great I'm
gonna give it just a name - he will be
24 in the season I want to say one other
thing there sometimes you read about
kids he grew up in the foster care
system with his three brothers and
after his father was deported to Guyana
all right this is a guy that's been
through a ton of stuff went to Alabama
played for Nick Saban won national
championships played with a running back
as his quarterback and is now going to
be with Julio Jones in Atlanta yeah
that's awesome it's also cool he gets to
go play for Atlanta his brother plays
for Georgia right now no that's pretty
family together I mean you go through
the foster care system and you're afraid
it means all these different places and
now you're all in the same spot that's
really cool all right let's do Calvin
Ridley to Atlanta and their eighth
ranked passing offense one of the best
moves in the history of the Atlanta
Falcons was getting a wide receiver from
Alabama named Julio Jones well some how
many perceived as the top wide receiver
in this draft from Alabama Falls to them
at 26 Calvin Ridley I feel like this is
fouled gold it is it really is and this
is a true best player available pick for
the Falcons I thought they were gonna go
D line here Ridley slips I think he was
the best overall receiver in the draft a
great route runner silky smooth on
braking routes he's not the biggest guy
but four for three speed and what he's
able to do on braking routes he's gonna
open up that offense and yeah they have
a lot of depth of receiver but I think
he could be a difference maker on
underneath he could play in the slot he
has the right body for that he's gonna
be a tremendous playmaker sir Cajun
connection here too well yes he played
he coached officer yeah so you don't
know where you're right I didn't even
think of that left go but certainly
knows him had this guys ready game day
one right away I mean there's no doubt
about that he was ready he's the most
polished wide receiver in the draft yes
was he my favorite receiver no but
there's really nothing to look at him
and go oh I don't like that part of them
I just don't think he's gonna be the
most explosive yards after catch type of
guy but he's gonna be able to win on the
outside you're gonna be scared of him
going deep by you he's gonna be able to
play the slot he's they catch the ball
over the middle so again for an offense
that's kind of needs a guy that can help
them right now it makes sense what
you're great for this but I gave it an
A+ I do like that you recognize a
strength when you got to a Super Bowl it
was with a great offense
Matt Ryan extend that window and with
Julio Jones deleting everything on
Twitter makes you wonder how long he's
gonna be in Atlanta anyway I'm gonna go
a - I like the player there's some
defensive guys on the board that I think
I would have considered with them I mean
this is the Falcons there's no Dante
repo there was tape and Brian on the
board Harold Landry's on the board this
is the Falcons I mean I they want pass
rushers I'm a little surprised they went
this route for such a successful offense
even with all of the lack of quarterback
play this guy caught a pass in all 44
games yes three seasons he's polished
and at this point of the draft it's a
heck of a fine Atlanta got themselves a
good one in Calvin Ridley Seahawks are
on the board is Harold Landry a thing I
mean I would think so or Darius guys see
on Jordan cliff Averill Marcus Smith and
Frank Clark are all free agents after
the season right my goodness
right it's an exodus of pass rushers
yeah I don't know if they're gonna rely
on the Barkevious Mingo but I think if
you match up Frank Clark
jarran Reed they got Shamar Stephens and
I just think Harold Landry is kind of
that need Josh Jackson being a really
good fit here - yes Josh Jackson
certainly would fit their scheme he
would definitely I this is a lot of
playing for them I yes they could do
Taven Brian - certainly I mean I look at
him what about Connor Williams for them
yeah I mean they could go off something
so that we landed we're gonna talk about
see how those offensive line all the
time and you got Connor Williams sitting
there I mean they they have so many will
James Daniel what's different this years
they let Tom Cable make their offensive
line picks in the past and he's gone I
mean they completely revamped this let's
play this case that leave that big board
up there who could they go with that
would really upset you
not that you would like that you go this
was unnecessary
I don't even know of those guys yeah
none I think all those guys would be a
good fit there they have a lot more
needs than people real they're decimated
yeah I mean that they need to rebuild
the secondary let me read the list of
guys that are no longer on the seahawks
from last year Paul Richardson Luke
Wilson Jimmy Graham Sheldon Richardson
Michael Bennett Richard Sherman Jeremy
Lane -
John shed Thomas Rawls all of those guys
left this off see right they got rid of
everybody what do you think's their
biggest need Sims how do you pick just
one of them it's it's it's so tough I
mean it's just cliff cliff cliff
April's injury issue kam chancellor we
don't know where he's right
right so you did look at that and right
away offensive line certainly always is
an issue Connor what do you think the
problem is Malik McDowell lat the last
second-round pick absolute dud nothing I
mean he gotten that aetbx
probably never and that forced them to
trade their second round or for Sheldon
Richardson but now he's gone so it's a
problem
becoming a revolving door why this is
why Taemin Bryan that is why taping
Bryan makes so much sense because he can
be that 3/5 very similar guy to shell
Richardson yeah I'll say this if your
interior deal line is jaren Reed and
Taven Bryant it's a heck of a
competition so we should talk about how
poorly they played the Sheldon
Richardson deal by the way make that
tree and give up Jermaine Kearse because
the Jets won't have been able to come
get Sam Donald tonight if it wasn't for
that trait so they got Jermaine Kearse
and were able to go get Sam darn old
because they trained it Sheldon
Richardson who wasn't even good in
Seattle and isn't even there oh they
took that pick and flipped it to him up
to three they they I know they offered
Richardson pretty good money though
I mean he decided he wanted to go on a
one-year better than himself as ideal
yeah I would rather play for Minnesota -
yeah right now it really could be a it
could be d tackle it could be a life
this is anything but quarterback yeah
really it could be any way I'm gonna go
tape and Brian what are you guys going I
mean I don't know I haven't seen the pic
man and they gave me the noise but I
don't have the I don't have the pic yet
I don't know maybe says on TV the pic
sent the Seahawks war room and they're
standing around like they got no idea so
I'm gonna go tape and Brian
Sims what are you going you know who
stole the board Harold Landry will
freaking Hernandez I know I know he was
always
like a late round okay I know you guys
loved him and I I do to be he was always
gonna be a twenty five to thirty to pick
okay
he's throwback guy sure yeah like
short-armed a little bit I love those
guys yeah I'm gonna go Harold Landry
again there's mean I've only said that
four times this day you guys are not
gonna believe this pic I had to ask
canvas they're in the control room three
times they looked like they didn't
believe the pic in the Seattle war room
they picked Rashad penny what yes
running back from San Diego State Rashad
round pick for some penny
I don't think read with that but I'm
still shocked he was the thirties the
third best running back in the draft for
me I would go Berkeley Michelle Rashad
penny but not right here this thing I've
ever heard on a team that has that many
holes this is so gonna take a running
back well the funny thing is is like
they have a plethora of running backs
Carson CJ Prosise JD mckissick Mike
Davis yes and you're gonna draft a guy
that's he's pretty good in the draft we
get excited right you get a great player
and you get super pumped and sometimes a
team drafts a guy and you go who the
hell is running things there Noah great
letter F take the cake F F laughs I so
bad Sims I'm gonna guess you got value
of this pig oh I'm going worse than
there's a pen guy he's getting a they're
getting a Dan they're getting a d-minus
how was that worse than enough it's not
he said I was gonna be - guys he's the
Mountain West Offensive Player of the
Year doesn't that congratulations
Donnelly was great in that offense -
Sims you actually like this player more
than most this is a value problem for
you right it's just a value problem I
like the player a lot like I said I
would go Berkeley Michelle Rashad penny
yeah but let's play a game
yes rather of Harold Landry yes of
course now looks like Foghorn Leghorn of
course not no lower body it's not the
most beautiful thing in the world
they passed up Haven Brian Harold Landry
all of the cornerbacks all of the tight
end prospects though
all of the offensive linemen and they're
high-fiving each other
Seattle wanted to change it they wanted
to get rid all these loudmouth guys and
change the culture if the culture you're
changing to is drifting Rashad penny
over all these guys you messed up let's
do a video though this one should be
good if I would have told Seahawks fans
that you could trade down multiple times
and you're sitting there with guys like
Harold Landry and tave and Brian you're
sitting there going this is a dream
scenario taking a running back with that
pick
I don't think factored in especially
when like Sony Michele still on the
board so what do you make of Rashad
Penny at this I tell you left go I'm so
happy right now because I'm a 49ers fan
I have no idea what the Seahawks are
doing this was the eighth best running
back on my board Wow we've talked about
this is one of the best running back
classes of all time and you're gonna
take a second to third round player in
the first round over Darius guys over
Sony Michele over carry on Johnson over
Nick Chubb over all the guys no idea how
to do it he doesn't even have great
vision I know the stats look amazing
congratulations Donnell Pumphrey looked
good in that offense man I hope I'm
wrong because I I do know you don't know
I'm good with this because I think this
is the worst pick of the draft well I
mean it's crazy to pick a running back
right here I would agree with that I
just didn't expect it does lose Shoni
Michele on the board but I will disagree
with everything else you said in that
statement ok this guy is the third best
running back in the draft he is special
he has got special feet you can't tackle
them one-on-one and nobody can catch him
and he can be a belt Cal he's 511 220
it's not the most perfect body I
understand it's not exactly what we
always usually look at her running back
but the film speaks for itself I really
like this kid I just don't like him at
the end of the 1st can you draft a
running back when you don't have an
offensive line how can you or a
defensive line or cornerbacks what
greater you given this pick if this is
an F and that's because they won't let
me go lower oh you give a d-minus no I
gave him an F I said fo- but ya know it
was an F - because it's just a bad pick
on every level the values
the need is wrong I don't even like the
scheme fit that much hmm I'm giving it a
bad grade okay what did I give it I gave
the d-minus but I'm just gonna say I
really like this player I just don't
know if it was necessary to take him
right now when you have other needs on
your football team that are pressing
certainly more pressing than running
back but man I will say the guy has
chance to be a special running back in
the NFL I think they want to redo it I
thought it was good I'm never gonna be
able to recreate the angle bro that was
that was okay why'd you want to redo it
yeah but who cares
oh the grade I definitely said F though
yeah right do you put all right guys
people listening out there this is on
the control room if you notice we're one
take Timmy's damn all right well the
Steelers pick is in is that Harold
Landry is that Taven Bryant I give up
is it Lamar Jackson oh dude I would love
Lamar Jackson replace Ben Roethlisberger
I heard they were taking his safety
the Seahawks traded down multiple times
they had a number of great defensive
players offensive linemen positions of
need they went a running back from the
Mountain West Conference Rashad Penny
what do you think Niners fan I want to
tell you something left go I'm so happy
right now because I'm a Niners fan I
don't know what they're doing drafting
the eighth best running back in the
class at the end of the first round you
don't have a no line you don't have
receivers you don't have a secondary you
know have a D line your rosters falling
apart you're a drafter running back this
is such a luxury pick this used to be
one of the best front office's in
football they have fallen apart I don't
know what John Schneider is thinking
here what do you think he's they go
listen to this guy okay he's not the
number eight running back in the in
college this year he's the third best
running back in the draft listen it's
crazy I don't expect them to do this
certainly not but I do like this player
I wrote in my notes he's the second best
open field runner I've seen in the draft
at the running back position he can run
by people he's got phenomenal feet
you're not gonna tackle him in the open
field so from that standpoint as a
player I really like him but my
comparison to him was a quicker footed
Jordan Howard what rounds is Jordan
Howard drafted in the fourth round I
believe so that is where I'm confused by
the thing I think they're trying to get
cute and like this is our Alvin Kamara
he's someone who's gonna help us on
returns and out of the backfield it's
just a luxury pick one they don't have
the roster to make this move you could
have gone so many different directions
Darius Geist if you want to run you back
so any Michelle if you want to running
back Nick Chubb carrion Jonathan Walton
it's an F F and they won't let me go
lower I would I'm giving it a d-minus
but just because of the position of the
pick and taking a running back that grow
running backs grown trees this day and
age sorry but man I do like this player
I really do it I will not be shocked a
few years from now if he's not at the
top of the NFL rushing leaderboard I
really won't be hmm I'll tell you what
though John Schneider he's gonna have to
answer some questions yes yes
so we'll see what he did Seahawks
running back for shod penny at 27
so I wrote and named Tyrell Edmund look
what I wrote down before we did the
video you thought it would be him it
just was Tyrell Edmonds safety Virginia
Tech yeah I love him I've told you about
it it is tremaine's brother if he had
been healthy slide he got flagged for
both knee and back issues a couple of
team there you go so that explains the
current slide for Harold there you go
right so we're gonna do Terrell Edmonds
for people that are watching in the
second screen Ryan I gotta find out that
was the moment that shifter was talking
about but I want to say walk with me
the Jaguars you're up now baby
every mock draft for months said Lamar
Jackson at 29 you are locked and loaded
at every position except for one you got
the seventieth best quarterback you got
the seventy-first best quarterback
backing them up like portals and cody
kessler you got Lamar freaking Jackson
Leonard fournette don't mess this up
Terrell Evans you're gonna MIDI well man
he got flagged medically from everyone I
talked to except for the Steelers we
have two brothers ever been drafted in
the first round ever I know you like him
a lot I do I mean this is about where I
thought he might go actually yeah I'm
gonna go I'm gonna give him an A - I
wrote 33 to 50 I mean so this isn't that
far off
I had him around alright whenever you
guys are ready okay so man two brothers
going in the first round how special is
that man and I will say seeing Ryan
shazier walk out there without any damn
special
okay he was a three star quarterback
recruited out of high school so he's 21
and his brothers 19 man so you're not
that big of a fan what do you think
about safety or a facility just that's
Mike so Tom at the versatility because I
look at the Steelers and I see Sean
Davis and Morgan Burnett and I didn't
think safety was gonna be that much of
it but Davis doesn't really play the
truth state he like a line like a nickel
in the Box kind of goes I can go on top
and let him roam yeah all right let's do
this video because we need that show cuz
the Jaguars pick is in and it better be
frickin Lamar Jackson Steelers first
pick is in they're a they're a legacy
organization they like family well they
took the second brother in the first
round the Edmonds Terrell Edmonds I
think everyone's heard about Jermaine I
need to learn about Tyrone yeah well he
is a versatile safety prospect and
someone I'll be it honest I did not
expect him to go first round I was not
expecting him to go second round because
shoulder issues an injury that shut him
down for 2017 was something that was
brought out to me often by teams of hey
this guy's flagged and this is a pretty
good safety class so where's the need to
get him I think he's more of like a
nickel linebacker almost more than he is
he's that over the top safety he's a guy
you're gonna play in the box and hope he
can cover some tight ends III really
liked this kid you know I'm a huge fan
of him I do think he's a true safety
free safety strong safety combination
he's gonna be able to get in the box
like Miller talks about he's extremely
athletic I mean he can run you can see
four four seven forty one and a half
inch vertical that just tells you how
explosive he is but this is the thing I
was also impressed with let go his
ability to cover receivers now he gets
beat on film but I would go no safety in
college football was asked to do what he
was asked to do so yeah there's a few
times he gets beat but man the
athleticism the tackling everything is
there
I think he's top-notch this is about
where I thought he could go into the
first round top of the second what crazy
given have you give it a D I thought he
was a third around player
he's an up side guy he's young I mean
like it's brother Tremaine he's a young
guy
obviously there's NFL bloodlines but I
see someone who has to get better
awareness he has to come to balance
better as a tackler and I'm just not
sure he was a need for a team that has
Sean Davis I'm Morgan Burnett I don't
know where you're gonna is your third
safety he's gonna play in the box yeah
well that's the way the NFL is right now
it's three safeties a little bit for a
lot of teams so I'm gonna go a here I
like this kid I told you there's nothing
I look at I wrote you know his his
movements his style of play reminds me
of Sean Taylor that's what I wrote yeah
I said I know he's not him but he's one
of the best safeties in the draft and
people are sleeping on this kid he is a
freak of nature and I think he's got a
bright future for the Steelers sure the
Steelers ago man we're gonna need to
keep you with the Patriots we need more
secondary guys and you got a shutdown
Titans he could be the guy however it's
pretty special Edmunds the second of two
brothers in the first round and he's go
to the Steelers legacy organization okay
so I think I think you could every Nixon
really that would be insane oh yeah I
forgetting we're on air if Jacksonville
doesn't pick Lamar Jackson very upset
they haven Brian he was there he was the
let's go to Connor
I do want to explain it after cuz I
think it makes a ton of sense it's
saving Brian yeah and here's what a lot
of people are missing Jacksonville is
gonna be like almost 40 million dollars
over the capital 2019 right and all that
money's tied up in Marcel Darius clays
cannibal Dante Fowler I believe his
fifth year yes option
once again thinking in the two to three
year window it's all about class
Campbell in the future and this is but
you know what Jacksonville is really
good at spotting talent at this position
yes and I guess the value was just too
good I'm just sitting here going I can't
believe Lamar Jackson is gonna follow
the Patriots a31 doesn't look like it's
gonna happen he's gonna go I know he's
your guy and like your route but I don't
know it was interesting to me though in
the last two weeks that's when all the
first rounds talked started and I got it
I got suckered into it as well because
everyone was saying yeah he'll go first
right and here we are with two three
picks left and he hasn't gone six five
to ninety one we've been talking about
Dave and Brian now for like 15 picks
what is haffley I mean great athlete I
think he's probably about her five
technique than his three technique yes
and there were times like his film was
not great but you knew that his first
step was amazing and that he was gonna
test out out of the world we had him on
the podcast this week super high
character guy dad his Navy SEAL hey but
he's that's why he's so much about you
he's gonna have to be developed and I
think also one talking about what Conner
was saying about the the contracts
coming up that entire defense is really
signed until 2019 except for the guys
that you were mentioning with those huge
contracts and then also Jaguars for 21st
against the run last year yeah it's a
part of their defense that they were
amazed against the capacity could sacked
a quarterback but the big guys in the
middle you didn't always hit the big
performances out of them no but you know
don't forget remember would we always
used to say about them they play for the
past they try to be bluffed for you with
the 8th guy at the line of scrimmage but
they're really playing past schemes up
front and in the secondary but so listen
holy cat hole we defensive line and Jack
oh my gosh hey hey hey
as well yep I mean that well my last
line was meant I wrote if Kim D Chi it
was a first rounder than Dan this kid
goes before the first pick so they're
d-line right now is yannick and gawk way
Dante Fowler a Bri Jones Marcel Darius
Malik Jackson coleus Campbell Mike
Bennett and out Taven Brian that is
insane
that's three defensive lines like Eagles
have a good - the Jaguars have three
defensive lines when you guys are ready
let's do this bad boy by the way I hope
Minnesota it takes well Hernandez oh
he's perfect right so great well person
will Hernandez Viking yeah they love
that cookie cutter
what if I told you that the best defense
in the NFL said we need another horse
and they got one son of a Navy SEAL
David Brian a mauler out of Florida 65
to 90 what do you think about this guy
at this pic I it's an upside pick he was
number 30 on my board overall flashed at
times on film tested much better than he
played so you don't need him to play
right away because you have all those
guys on the divine light class Campbell
like Marcel Darius he's gonna be the
future for that position get stay in the
home state of Florida and he's just in
two years he's gonna be so much better
than he is right now because he's
finally gonna come into his own
typically he's from technically from
Wyoming but what do you who does he
remind you of a poor-man's JJ Watt I
mean that's what he he's impressive I am
I'm a huge fan of this kid I really am I
mean I am impressed with everything that
get off the explosion the ability to
shed blockers the ability to hold his
ground at 291 verse double-teams it's
pretty good for a guy that size I mean
he's got big-time ability he's going to
be a handful he could be a three
technique he could be a five technique
if you want to play a different type of
defense damn he's athletic enough if you
said you know what we're playing a
running team this week we got to get
really big you put Marcel Darius inside
and a Bri Jones inside and then he got
coleus and Brian on the outside and say
good luck today I don't know what green
do you give a team now that has a spoil
of riches I gave it an A and I love the
value was great and I love the
Jacksonville's thinking ahead about
building this team they didn't panic and
draft a quarterback didn't panic and go
interior offensive line they got a guy
that in two to three years formative JJ
Watt I love it yeah yeah that's how I
saw and I'm with you I'm giving an A as
well because it is thinking in the
future and man the NFL you just can't
have enough good defensive linemen right
now I mean especially if you're going to
beat New England and Tom Brady and the
Patriots because that's who's gonna be
there at the end this year
you need to have pass rushers like the
Philadelphia Eagles that can win the
game at the end and Jacksonville
couldn't get to Tom Brady in the fourth
quarter to end that game I'm gonna get
this tonight should have taken the
margin even Brian though building for
the future the Jaguars
just keep getting bigger and badder like
Vikings with a great pick Minnesota with
what taking one of my favorite players
in the dream to deliver it to Connor and
Mike use you see I took my cue take
another corner they are just he's just
doing Cincinnati High just gonna stack
corners sacking them so the Vikings take
UCF corner Mike Hughes by the way you
can't call it Central Florida they get
mad so they have really they have three
first-round corners and a second-round
corner trae Waynes Xavier Rhodes
McKenzie Alexander and Mike Hughes yes
three first let me want to talk about
this guys closer to Denzel war than
people are ready alright so why did he
last this long when he was at North
Carolina originally he was accused of
sexual assault right a + got kicked at
dismissed suspended dismissed ended up a
Garden City can you get charged to the
old charges Plus no charges no charges
okay all right and then one year UCF so
he's like a one year wonder but he is a
great return man mmm sticky corner and
he will talk about it on the video but
he's very good I know this I think this
was Sims his favorite corner it was the
first round is almost over I know it
kind of went fast but it's it's 11:30 so
I didn't go that fast never mind
you like to [ __ ] a lot I do man I think
this kid is I think it's the man-to-man
cover corner yeah I agree
in the draft and you know what that Rupp
the return thing Marcus Cheryl's is a
don't do that
Marcus Charles is a free agent after the
season so he could take over the
returning duties as well right he's
gonna be if he they want to put him a
punt returner he is gonna be in the
conversation pretty crazy the the
Jaguars the Vikings just improved their
defenses they had and I'm let the
Vikings really gonna use the card they
have up your but Jobu pics yeah they can
just go we could pick the best player
available he reminded me so much of
Pacman Jones yeah a little bit bigger
but yep yep
Vikings got to the NFC Championship game
and they really get there on defense and
they add a guy that probably shouldn't
have been there at 30 some extenuating
circumstances in this past but Mike
Hughes an athlete at a UCF athlete at a
UCF one of the best corners in the class
probably the best return man in the
class as well yeah there were some awful
things that's why he's still here but he
is a sticky cover man he is tough at the
line of scrimmage plays with an attitude
I had him ranked as the number 26
overall player so the value is
definitely there
and that's factoring in some of those
all field issues that teams were a
little concerned about kind of a
one-year wonder a UCF is a JUCO kid
before that yeah but he was dynamite
this year he nobody gets open against
this kid is my favorite yeah it's my
favorite corner in the draft this is
he's the best pure man-to-man cover
corner for me in the draft his ability
to jam receivers at the line of
scrimmage turn and run break on the ball
he doesn't give the receiver in the
quarter bag anything he fights to get
the ball out of there he is phenomenal
in that standpoint tough as hell gonna
talk crap and you know what else they
does he is all over the field he Hawks
anybody if you think you're gonna run
for a 70 yard touchdown with him on the
field Wow good luck cuz he's gonna come
get you look at that can they save your
Rhodes and him and then trae Waynes
running all over the pits insane when I
think he'll probably in the slot oh I
gave it an A+ not only is he gonna help
a defense that's already one of the best
in the NFL he's gonna be a great return
man and like we always talked about you
got to compete with the top teams in
your conference in your division he's
gonna help them do that
yeah I'm gonna eight plus as well I mean
this is one of the best players in the
draft and here he is being taken at the
end of the first round by the Minnesota
Vikings for a team that's gonna be in
the Superbowl conversation but tough
physical the movements the twitchiness
you got to see him cover Cortland Sutton
big receiver out of SMU he's got right
up in his face it was no problem he's a
star I think a lot of people were
expecting the Vikings to take an
interior offensive lineman there's still
a bunch left yeah I don't know if there
was a Mike Hughes left in this trap the
Vikings and that Mike Zimmer defense
they collect corners get in line
Vikings coming at you
all right is there we are patriots your
are let's guess let's guess yeah you
just guess Lamar left go it's not
they're not trapped in a 13 Wonderlic
quarterback in New England they are very
comfortable with his you think they I
know you wouldn't no idea I don't think
he's the pic though but no I don't think
he will be either they're our team that
they're trying to win the Super Bowl
this year too so it's it's it's it's I
know they're thinking in the future but
it's like they are with jokes I would
guess it guesses before it comes up on
so good I want Dallas got hurt here but
I don't think that's who it is a good
guess I'm gonna go Isaiah Oliver is
there a position its offense I'm not
giving you ants how mad are you as a
Jets man oh we got slammed Arnold uh-oh
I'm going Carlton Davis yeah that's what
I was going all right well Davis earlier
in the first round they took Isaiah win
and now they took Sony Michelle the guy
that he opens up the way that Georgia
rushing attack right yeah okay so they
lost the Ann Lewis they all steal on
Lewis they sign Jeremy hill their
current running backs are Rex Burkhead
Jeremy hill James White I don't know
this pic I don't know if I like this pic
for that I do for me I I intercedes a
good player Connor but you lose Malcolm
Butler and you're sitting there with an
Isaiah Oliver on the board will they
find Jason McCourty I think they're
probably comfortable with that I don't
know if I am or Carlton Davis I to be
honest Sims has been pitching Carlton
Davis I love a perfect Patriots player
in terms of that scheme absolutely but I
mean I seem to be all over the place
with them I've seen some people that
love them and some don't yeah they got a
lot of running backs though guys
naughty good ones this is what they do
but this listen I think Sony Michelle
was the second best running back in this
draft okay so you're seeing some wow I
would I would have taken the under of
three running backs in the first like I
was havin Kamara man what are we
thinking on great Sam you know I mean
watching him in the championship playoff
we just give me a 2 seconds Connor and
here I come
like uh you know what if I'm Philly
who the hell's they take the first round
Isaiah when Isaiah with you hmm like
Georgia I'm just trying to think what
else is out there that could have
totally been a so I had Connor Williams
Harold Landry Josh Jackson James Daniels
Isiah Oliver I think that the Eagles are
gonna take Tallis coder I can see that I
know I'm gonna go away by this Connor
all right we got Miller with an A
Simpson an a-minus Gadar I hope they go
Carlton do this seems really early for
him who Carl's and Davis you're saying
yeah well we just saw a shot penny going
no joke exactly the teams have Carlton
Davis is there from one of their top
five corners yeah all right let's do
Sony Michelle this is one of the most
exciting players and the draft going to
one of the best teams the NFL the New
England Patriots New England is a team
that every game you don't know who's
toute in the rock all of a sudden it's
this no-name running back well when Bill
Belichick takes a running back that tore
up college football in the first round
this might be the feature guy going
forward Sonne Michelle you both love
this guy yeah he should be the future
back moving forward and he can help you
in the past game so he's gonna give you
a lot of the things that Dion Lewis did
but he's a better runner he was the only
guy who could get around the edge
against Alabama when Nick Chubb couldn't
he can't out the rock with speed I loved
his burst his wiggle I had him at 33
overall and he comes off at 31 and I
think the Patriots saw a little alvin
kamara in his tape said let's just find
a way to get the ball in this guy Tammy
he's gonna be very familiar following
his other first-round pick Isiah win the
guard from Georgia that went at 23 well
and for a team that's looking for guys
that can make plays with the ball in
their hands which they don't have in New
England that's where this guy makes
sense and yes we also know that they
know how to utilize their running back
in the pass game he is Alvin Kamara
with a guy that I think has just got
more power than Kamara as in between the
tackles runner
Wow he's special I mean listen I
don't care it's the SEC the final four
of this championship game he's running
for 50 and 60 yard touchdowns on the
best college teams in football so I
expect that to happen and once the NFL's
career starts as well man so you look at
the Patriots right now Chris Hogan
cordarrelle Patterson could be all over
the place but they lose em in dhola
Adelman's coming off an injury he could
be a big part of this offense what grade
D I gave it an A I think he will be a
big part of the offense and I've said it
so many times the one of the best ways
to take pressure off of quarterbacks is
give them a running back yeah takes
pressure off Tom Brady Sonny Michelle is
gonna do that Sims I'm gonna give it to
a - I mean this is a position that is
very important to the New England
Patriots they're gonna split them out
slot receiver he's gonna be between the
tackles runner they're gonna get them on
the edge in the run game but he's a
well-rounded football player tough as
hell a playmaker they need somebody
explosive on their offense that's why I
like it Patriots are loading up for
another Super Bowl run a weapon and a
downhill blocker solid first-round picks
from the state of Georgia for the New
England Patriots
yeah Eagles have traded their pick to
the Baltimore Ravens a team that I've
been talking about all along could be
the spot for Lamar Jackson use this hey
I got some news for you oh crap it's not
it is yes
Lamar Jackson he saw and so not only do
they get Hayden Hearst the best tight
end in the draft they're gonna give him
the weapon for Lamar Jackson
Marty mourning Wegg and Lamar baby boy
think about who's a run game coordinator
yep the Reg Roman X X often capital on
Kaepernick in the San Francisco 49ers
knee kind of knew that the Eagles pick
was gonna be up for grabs because if you
get a first-round pick you get a
fifth-year option and for a quarterback
it's very valuable this is exactly what
happened with Teddy Bridgewater Lamar
Jackson is going to Baltimore
he's a first-round pick he's ready to go
man I'm in love with this cuz I think
that's a perfect spot for him I just
don't know how they're gonna do this
with Joe Flacco now well it's okay he's
not ready yet I think
rg3 signing him was like a telltale sign
that they were thinking about this I
mean that may be that they were thinking
about going along those lines
I don't know around him that's a valid
point I'm not I don't know if I wanna
know sarcastic okay I know I think yeah
yeah I you think rg3 good listen like I
like how do you do yo I'm gonna mentor
this guy Leo RG I don't know either
are you guys happy with this right I am
extremely happy it's a great spot yeah
I'm uh I'm gonna give this a plus this
is my guy right here I'm a big fan as
well so why he's excited we're excited
it's just because we just were so taken
aback by the Bill Polian take so we went
hands we went back again stupidity yeah
what grade did you give hey hey is a
great spot for him man they got him man
Hayden Hearst and Lamar Jax and that
offense looks completely different now
and with Willie Snead crowd she and John
Brown the question is do you put Lamar
in it at a receiver a little and you're
one to get him used to the speed of the
game get used to hearing the calls in
the huddle get used to oh I'm hot off of
these receivers these are all things
that will translate to his quarterback
career I think that's the interesting
dynamic in this combo and he was
disappointed he was still on the board
you can tell oh I'm sure yeah you know
he's gonna use that as motivation all
right let's do this
I'm happy as hell for this guy man we
thought the first round was over we
thought that Lamar Jackson was gonna sit
in the green room and open up his jacket
and say who's gonna come get me and Here
Come their Ravens the Ravens I got a
note for you this guy is gonna turn
around the franchise real quick Lamar
Jackson
what do you think can he get in right
away can we see this oh no he's not gay
Joe Flacco was a Superbowl Lefko you're
crazy you're punch drunk at the end of
the draft right no Lamar Jax is a
developmental prospect who does have to
clean up some things mechanically he has
a great arm
he's a dynamic runner he's one of the
most electric players I've seen in
college football in all my time covering
it but he has to learn there are things
he's gonna have to get better at and
they're gonna have to change their
system to accept him you can't run the
same offense for him at Joe Flacco no
this is about the future of the
Baltimore Ravens and it is a very good
pick but he's not gonna field right now
unless Joe Flacco gets hurt and that's
why it's interesting they got RG three
in the offseason what do you think about
Marty mourning wegg horror ball bryggen
Lamar Jackson with Joe Flacco they're
introducing them I love it I mean and
then also Greg Roman is the run game
coordinator who coached Colin Kaepernick
and that offense out there in San
Francisco so he's gonna have a plethora
of design quarterback runs did to call
but either way I'll say this about Lamar
Jackson is here aw yeah certainly he's a
quarterback let me just tell you he
plays the position the way it should be
played he throws the ball way he doesn't
take sacks yes is the throwing perfect
no it's not there's some mechanic
issues like Matt Miller talked about he
needs to clean those up but I will say
this you get away from college football
there's no no no more 20-hour rule
you're in a facility with coaches on you
all day three 365 seven days a week
those mechanic is mechanical issues are
not gonna bother me he can throw the
ball and then let's not forget he's the
most gifted runner we've ever seen at
the position other than Michael Vick and
he was the best player on the field and
every ACC game I watched your first
college player to have back-to-back
3,000 yard passing 1000 yard rushing
seasons your grade trading up to get
Lamar Jackson hey I love the trade up
because you get five years with him
which is so important for his
development also because you do have a
quarterback there that one year was
Superbowl you can't just kick him
completely out the door here the tail
end of his career so I really like the
pic I know you guys do as well yeah I've
been asking for it all night yeah yeah
no I do it's an a pick for me because
it's the perfect situation to just for
him to sit behind Joe Flacco a little
bit what did I do a play plus what am I
talking about is Lamar Jackson let's go
Baltimore but yes I love this position
he's in sit behind Joe Flacco learn the
NFL game I wouldn't be shocked if you
throw him out a receiver let him hear
Joe Flacco called the plays in the
huddle let them understand the speed of
the game oh this guy makes me hot as a
quarterback I got to know that as a
receiver too it'll all translate so this
is not just a project where we're not
gonna see him on the field for two years
they'll find ways to get in there here
exactly right exactly right
Lamar Jackson easily one of the most
dynamic electric and splendid players to
come out in this trap and they get him
that 50 er option if this is a redshirt
year that last year is so important
Lamar Jackson the future faced by the
Baltimore Ravens
all right now on a serious note what are
the Eagles get for that don't hit a halt
and overall pick in the draft a second
round or next year in another late round
pick okay
no you didn't have any that's a gift of
second round or next year too with that
it's just to go back out we're on 32 to
52 I don't give a [ __ ] getting up as
soon as I don't know I need to stand up
alright so looking at the first round in
general what was what were some of the
best picks in your minds I think Derwin
James at 17 we're all feeling that I
think Mike Hughes at 30 was a great pick
Quintin Nelson at 6 Bradley Chubb at 5
and Edmonds at 16 Tremayne Evans at 16
I'm in the first round I did not have
there was not too many guys I disliked
in the first round this year I mean I
think the other thing too is the Harold
Landry fall with something higher oh
yeah so of course well I mean Miller
seta and our Conner reported it I mean
the fact that there's that kind of
medical issue out there that's a lower
back knee injury for a pass rusher
that's that's bad are you surprised that
will Hernandez is still in the blue I am
surprised I thought that he would go
somewhere between 20 and 32 but I don't
think Miller's is surprised that he's
still no I'm really not I mean he's a
good player but we saw a run on interior
offensive lineman so it's just that
there are gonna be seven interior
offensive lineman or worst pick on the
first round I know you know I know
everybody's a shot don't know I go Colt
Miller called Miller's up there hope
Miller was a bad pick and at least trade
it back Baker Mayfield that one was the
worst pick of the first round I'm sorry
that's just that's the truth of the
matter I think it was Rashad penny I
didn't like Edmonds either to Pittsburgh
they could have to make they could have
took Baker met Mayfield that for and got
say Quan Berkeley at one and nothing
went and they would been yeah for me I
think that the team that did the best in
this draft other than like the single
guys the bills getting Josh Allen and
Jermaine Edmonds is really inquiry
really incredible when I when I read
back was nice I don't real I don't think
I realized how close I actually had
Rashad Penny and so on it's shown Sony
Michele excuse me I couldn't spit that
out one of my favorite picks
the first round that I'll say though
that cuz we didn't get to do videos this
year and you didn't get to read through
my notes ax is the safety Pittsburgh
duck Jermaine Edmunds brother Tyrell I
see you guys are complete personal man I
love Tyrell I just didn't think anybody
would have the guts to actually caught
but that was where I've liked when I put
at the end of my notes I put he was
gonna go somewhere between 30 and 30 and
45 the other one I think it was a great
pick is if you can get Minka Fitzpatrick
at 11 for the dolphin yes yes worked out
really well yeah alright guys that was
the first round we are going to be back
tomorrow live YouTube be R at Facebook
we're doing the second and third round
it's gonna be us three and Connor Sims
gonna do the second round with us and
then I'm leaving and he's bouncing out
how to enough of this crap look man
we're gonna give it to you straight
unfiltered raw and we're only gonna
focus on the players because that's the
only thing that matters Miller good
stuff thanks man
Sims good stuff he's a Conner Lily Lily
good stuff guys thank you so much join
us wherever you want to watch tomorrow
you know what to do bleeped your report
we are with you holler at you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]